salut stouff bonjour tout le monde
salue famille fallu à tous bravo tu t'es
pas trompé cette fois ci je réfléchis
avant de parler d'elle en matière
alors on est de retour tout pour la
ronde numéro 11 de tata steel donc on se
rapproche de la fin d'une petite journée
de repos hier
et protégerait de repos bah je sais pas
si c'est là où est arrivé mais on a une
nouvelle peine vous l'avez vu déjà sur
les réseaux sociaux c'est que daniel
pipes of été testé positif
aux colis donc il ne jouera pas
aujourd'hui ni les deux dernières rondes
du tournoi
ouais c'est ça donc
bon ça pousse un peu le tournoi merci
que ces résultats sont quand même mon
compte off la règle c'est que le joueur
a disputé plus de la moitié au moins en
tout cas la moitié des partis donc dans
ce cas la garde ces résultats et on lui
met un forfait pour les délais les
parties restantes et notamment steph la
dernière ronde des jeux contre un autre
15 nous bloque donc à celle qui est déjà
en tête bénéficie d'un point gratuit ce
qui fait que il ya quasiment l'occasion
de la somme et le tournoi s'il s'impose
aujourd'hui réalité
alors après je suis pas sûr que 400 fois
ci comptant abba dont vous avez vous
cache pas que faire ça deux s'est réjoui
du fait que tout peuple soit malade même
du guépard foire fait c'était juste
le sportif mais en fait les blancs est
pour lui une occasion pour marc des pros
oui bien sûr il disputera que deux
rondes c'est ce qu'on vit le rat est ce
qui fera quand même si blanches et
noires certainement tout ce n'est pas
parce qu'il ya des gens qui m'ont
peut-être sauvé sur le resto avec cinq
plans et 7 thors
et tu vois guy qui avait gagné par
forfait contrôle du boeuf au final ça
équilibre un petit peu un par rapport à
un joueur donc là on a quand même
richard rapport qui bénéficie à ce point
grave du contrôle du prof
prada qui va juste après et 40 cents
soit 23 joueurs plus guy maintenant oui
les malades d'ailleurs il a été positif
aux copines se rappelèrent il y avait
des capitaux et quelques ronds dans quoi
ils avaient refusé de jouer avec le baas
parce que quelqu'un de proche de son
entourage était positive en attendant le
test est pas voulu jouer avec le masque
et ils avaient partie perdue elle
finalement tu m'as quelques jours après
il a été contacté jacques sens qu'il est
temps aussi que le tendance était en
ville parce que du coup il a joué hier
donc l'adversaire d'hier de toubab ctek
east où s'était frotté plus où les bulls
vous pose pas impossible non plus le
gros des lustres maintenant
par cagliari est ce que les gens
racontent à d'autres oeuvres où il reste
plus que trois jours donc ça devrait
pouvoir finir les grecs mais la victoire
pourrait se jouer beaucoup
en fait il est vrai avant tu vois au
niveau de restriction d'eau guidon
masquer tous à contester tous les jours
et tout mais il touche comme les mêmes
pièces la même pendule épuisera pour
jouer le basket dont la plupart le
poisson chat noir c'est ça les doubles
ne l'a pas pour jouer parce que c'est
d'ailleurs ça qui
servent au point qu'elle a fait un peu
compris guéri il voulait pas mettre le
masque ouais l'interface est très
intéressant car il a soutenu cette fois
ci alors qu'il y avait eu des échanges
un peu houleux
mais interposés du fait que du bois que
les secours des cars scène pendant le
championnat du monde l'espèce de
trahison après carrière
patriotiques on va dire par rapport à
des propos ce qui nous semble assez
grotesque cette fois ci il a dit que lui
donc le 2 j'aurais jamais avec un masque
que tout poil avec tout à fait j'ai vu
ça aussi j'ai lu ça aussi oui je me suis
posé question pourquoi il faisait ça
j'ai peut-être que veut-il voulu montrer
qu'il avait rien de personnel montereau
de bord us contre l'action qu'il avait
intrigué mais fait mais je sais pas si
c'est assez étrange mais après
moi je pense que ça prend un bon moi je
suis pas du tout lui ni rue mais mais
s'ils pensent qu'en suisse coop que qu'à
contacter battu mais le masque puis tu
t'es quoi oui voilà ce qu'est ce que
t'es qu'un contact c'est vraiment sa
place à une partie et après si tu te
tais ce que puis on verra ainsi qu'une
seule partie ouais bon c'est pas la fin
du monde
du coup c'est l'internet
s'intéresse en séries mais de voir que
tu es joueur de ce niveau et ont
l'impression que c'est un vrai handicap
les basques en tout cas eu d'élection se
ressentir puisque ils disent ça
devaney d'accord pas agréable en été
mais de là je sais pas si c'est dur à
dire moi j'ai fait beaucoup de temps
avec le masque et pour dire vraiment le
ressenti
quand vraiment il fait très chaud genre
en été ou quoi j'avoue que c'est
difficile de dire si ce n'est pas ce
qu'a écrit chaude où transpirent avec
bâle a fait du mal à respirer là c'est
très agréable là je pense qu'ils ont
comme des conditions de jeu qui doivent
être ramassées bonne intro fois les
caméras et en costard et où je pense en
plus d'abriter très froid en hiver ici
bas cette perte de l'année donc
il n'y a pas eu d'accident mais je
pensais juste par principe je pense par
principe m il proclame un handicap par
rapport aux autres joueurs ou peut-être
qu'il voulait juste faire son coup de
gueule mais
enfin tu pas vraiment du câble à la
ramasse
comme ça ça peut être
tout le monde c'est un ressenti
différent d'un jour à l'autre
mais bon oui mais toujours est il que
pour la 7 mois ci malheureusement
il sera pas parmi nous pour la fin de
tournoi
n'a pas nié la moindre partie
c'est vrai pour lui ai d'ailleurs stouff
la question dispose c'est que
dubois qui devait disputer les grands
prix fidh il a d'ailleurs invité dans
ces grands prix et ça commence le 4
février je crois que quatre dans une
semaine
et du coup je sais pas s'il pourra jouer
quoi ça va être alors non non c'était
vacciner à 20% après yaya pétrin elle
est positif côté positif le bougeant
mais normalement marceau variant la
techno deep même pas une semaine au
rebond ces jeux c'est mon domaine
c'est mais faut voir après pouvoir après
peut-être que nous l'avait un peu plus à
ce sujet là parce que françois travaille
dans le domaine médical et du petit il
est plus grand que nous pour ces choses
là et
pour répondre à deux ans d art alors
première chose c'est que dubaï j'ai
travaillé depuis longtemps avec
carrousel quel que soit son adversaire
il avait donné son accord
de travailler de nouveau pour ce
match-là du monde avec 15 sel avant de
connaître le nom du challenger donc
avant que débogage les candidats que je
pense que même si on avait déjà connu il
aurait même accepté mais déjà ça là sont
des éléments qui viennent en plus pour
porter le son choix est tout à fait
légitime au regard des pratiques seront
cet exemple on a leur entrée ce n'est
qu'il secondes bac 1 scène depuis
longtemps le ford est français si un
match chacun sait déjà
par personne va dire il faudrait que
laurent a un peu traîné
car scène pour ce match sans nom mais en
fait c'est le montage des différents
comprend la russie et
l'europe on n'a pas du tout la même mais
la pensée vital séance et leurs déchets
verts ici les différents états et
donc
tu vois
c'est normal même même si mac l'image la
plus tôt maxime que rosa je dirais puis
max comme le vrai franck sait plus où
temps
et pas non mais par exemple match est
écartée car ces mêmes vlb impressionné
continuera trail programme bien
sûr ou jalousie bien sûr mais moi en
fait maxime est fasciné un se
connaissent très bien que très longtemps
et son ami tu as donc du coup c'est pire
un
complexe mais bon c'est comme ça on est
bon on en reparlera peut-être un peu
plus tard dans ce très bon c'est vrai
textures bien ça me scie on va peut-être
se concentrer sur les partis qui vont
bel et bien aujourd'hui ce tout avec
donc au premier et chic et 15 celle qui
a eu l'occasion de faire à sa fille dit
oui alors j'aime qu'en plus je connais
un peu cette ouverture je l'avais
travail et
donc en fait c'est donc s'appelle loire
du coût 85 il faut se battre pour
satisfaire et
c'est pour éviter en fait en fait poussé
quatre c'est pour éviter la défense
russe la défense être là la preuve avec
havas l'étroit canal et m6 qui est prêt
égalisant et en plus c'est vraiment un
joueur de défense plus donc enfin décide
à bord et
est du coup en fait poussé 400 empêche
donc vous ces quatre cavaliers detroit
et là maintenant on va voir comment il
va réagir jusque là mal m'en sur detroit
il ya deux coups soit il joue cavalier
c6 et c'est de transposer dans le but d'
alien sauf que la bunge et j'aurais plus
tard possible et aider à mettre 4
qui pas forcément très très mou mais qui
existent mais sinon
le coup ici un dans la grande ligne cc6
au jeu des cinq énormes joue cavalier f3
et diana rigg avait une partie très
marrant tu vas souvenez la fameuse coupe
du monde j'étais à un moment c'était
wade dit qu'on trouve ding je pense et
une partie marrant tard tâche que l'on
souvenir des cinq loubet 3 atteint
second souviennent
s'il y avait eu comme résultat ça fait
nul mais to b 4 ou des deux
grands cavaliers emprise en quatre
gammes en cavale et
ensuite à prendre en prendre deux fois
prison 1,4 qu'avec des cinq
noms frais d'entretien complet qui l'a
retrouvée sur nos marges moins sympa ce
théâtre on t'envoie je peux je peux je
peux à trouver
en fait il y avait il y avait une
entente avec sacrifice de pièces
et est
choisie ou de dix minutes de retard mais
nous conte donc on ne sait pas on trouve
extraordinaire ans il a bien sacrifier
son beau joueur même s'il a du mal à
confirmer par contre n'ont jamais un
petit peu d'échecs de côté tout par les
stars des plus jeunes grands maîtres de
l'histoire le joueur chinois
très religieux l'avion tu vas tu
cherches la partie alors pouvoir la
caméra quinzaine d heures de balade
s'est il est parti chercher
la partie
ça c'est drôle en fait le point la
théorie en fait c'est drôle d'enquêté on
avait découlé de ce programme prend à
présent le gars qui permet de prendre 5
h et j'en suis à detroit c'est bien
c'est si c'est pour savoir c'est si du
coup on disait qu'elle élève trois des
cinq poules et 3
tu prends d'emprunt est lassé des
princes 4 km et points 5
5 un petit rock
des prend le 4 est bon si tu manges
qu'elle va les prendre et qui peut par
contre oui parce qu'elle croyait cette
emprise donc du coup ça va il faut je
dois me cet
essai d'un mètre quatre des
cavaliers h5 on peut étudier à temps tu
lui as parlé de caisse et là le coup
c'est joli c'est fou prend à cette
échelle est en fête
dimanche c'est du moins je mange tout et
puis j'ai quand même une tournée de
pions pour la pièce et ça
c'est à peu près la partie mais a pas eu
ça ok ils iront ensuite
et ce roi a chuté et le très très jolie
dame jetteront
j'ai dit ça c'est pour eux et c'est pour
ça en fait voilà
dans la rue
regardez bien s'ils mangent la dame est
recouvert d'un linge du
canadien cad à 6 h pour les 6 h 30 et 3
kg pour un profond
émoi
et
voilà
donc ça c'est être esthétique c'était
cette fois la coupe du monde alors que
je serai pas en 2015 c'est
en découvrant la colonne est cher et est
du coup en fait l'idée c'est que sur
sur dame g3 bagdad a mangé la dame sinon
regardez bien avant de manger des pièces
comme ça parce qu' il peut y avoir des
pièges et donc les yeux juste au coin
f700 de tout le monde en est cette dame
des 6 et après en fait il a joué avec
deux pions une tour pour deux pièces
d'or
datant du préfet largement il dit
préférer les blancs parce que le
conducteur en croquer cavaliers un petit
port jeu mais au final radec c'était
compliqué tu n'as tu es nul hein c'était
à wailly contre ding en 2015 coupe du
monde d'après un super des ars qui palpe
et elle fait sourire parce que c'est pas
tous les jours tu vois comme ça
c'est comme ça vous pouvez ravaux voilà
juste vécu et hume état d'âme et sans
verbe nacelle
paradoxe a battu le nac moi quelque
chose là juste normal a
donc ça c'est la partie de cookies qui
avait connu avec ça et du coup si tu
veux en venir à detroit on n'aura pas ça
parce que je t'annonce qu'il avait rêvé
voilà la bouffe dommage parce que parce
que bon du coup je transpose dans
l'hôtel avec un maillet froid mais au
moins 45 jours italienne et il a pas il
n'a pas joué
mais du coup un prêt d'alien
s'est récemment l'italien a été joué pas
mal pour essayer de gagner parce que
vous voyez que les espagnols et on avait
du mal à passer ouais et donc du coup
c'est un choix pour être un avantage
donc cavale c3 c'est une variante ok
donc généralement au jeu plutôt avec ses
3 1 soit pas la langue hongroise avec
cavalli des deux cavaliers shanghai les
3es mais qu'avec trois social coûts qui
se joue pas mal et bon l'idée ça fait
rage outre cabaye des 500 j'appelle
cavaliers pour changer la pièce qui
défend le roi et puis après probablement
joué à 7,3 des cafards mais bon moi ya
pas trop trop d'avantagés si pour les
pros les blanc et noirs lesquin 7 juin
une partie
c'est une partie mais du coup est ce que
on aura suffisamment de jeu enfin moi je
me posais pas la question parce que bien
sûr c'est une partie bien sûr qu'arsène
doit essayer de trouver quelque chose
mais enfin tu vois en fait
car ce n'est venu jouer depuis son égal
essayer de grind
également moi j'ai moi j'ai peur que ce
soit trop plein et bah moi ça
m'intéresse que j'ai l'impression que je
joue et ça quand j'étais petit est un
peu tout le monde air france a débuté
quand j'avais je sais pas
avant quand il se fait donc la boue
barkat le sort nous foulée de chevaux et
je vais rockets et les noirs ils font
paraître symétrique des petits pots dans
l'impression de voir une partie un peu à
celle et b à brac il respecte les
techniques de base et on voit que même
au champion du monde ça ne m'inspire de
ce principe de base donc c'est pour vous
dire à quel point c'est important même
qu'on vous quand vous jouer juste c'est
de jouer simple souvent de pâtes pas
vouloir trop en faire
on peut se permettre d'en perdre
guillemets trop plus on devient vivant
au début vous vraiment s'appuyer sur des
choses solides et déjà si vous faites un
juste une ouverture à vous sortez vos
pièces vous prenez impulsion vous mettez
votre foi l'abri ou par sur des bonnes
bases et après on peut commencer quelque
chose même
meilleur joueur du monde
il par là dessus donc ça va être maroc
amis de voir comment y laisser un petit
peu de prendre l'avantagé du rsa fait
réfléchir dit james tout bas il se pose
des questions qu'est-ce qui m'a préparé
c'est vrai que ça allait voilà un petit
peu enfantin gros
on va dire que c'est le genre de joueur
que tu apprends ben en fait c'est la
première bourrasque couture pendant pas
vu sur tes pièces ont tué les pions 30
cavaliers les foutus rock est bon c'est
une ouverture vraiment que j'ai pas au
bout après deux heures ou deux heures de
cours m'a pris deux leçons des pièces
jusqu'à reprendre un jour au centre ce
que montre à quoi ouais c'est ça je
pensais mais versera plus populaire chez
au japn france poussent à ce contrat
depuis le plus voir sur l'échiquier
avoue dernier séjour de l'opposition
salue violette la fenêtre
donc ok on va laisser désirer fléchir ce
que l'on va aller se brosser retraite
sur l'échiquier numéro deux avec un
badge elle intéressante pour cent les
irlandais entre les deux premiers
ex-aequo de l'édition de l'an passé à
savoir bordeaux restait guère il est bon
de voir ce qu elle est coiffée à son
aîné en départage qu'elle ait créé la
surprise à dépasser donc à voir cl
d'hier il envie de prendre une petite
revanche aujourd'hui il y avait bien
évoqué donc des six ok donc c'est une
position assez standard
dans cet échange est une sorte de ragoût
chine avec une prise dans ces trois des
six à meucon coupe
ils donnent clairement leur attention et
vos maîtres nous faut peut-être dans la
grande diagonale m6 dans ses variantes
il va parfois aux assises où il peut
revenir baisse et abandonnait voir tout
de suite consolider les centres et jouer
contre autrefois cette diagonale ou
simplement pourquoi il joue tout seul
battre les joueurs ont moitié lever 1
pendant les parties doivent se lever
pour être volés et de l'or se lève à
chaque fois et on a beaucoup de temps la
bande du lin donc on a le temps d'aller
se promener un petit peu
vite savoir la fa non vertueux il n'ya
pas besoin d'être trop concentrés pour
l'instant ils sont à peu près dans des
chemins qui connaissent ou qu'ils ont
généré près pareil
tarascon la partie devient tendue est
quand même plus ainsi même ça dépend des
joueurs qu'ils adorent se passer dépasse
de descendre entre carsen et les po je
pense que l'epo vous l'avez vu plus
souvent en dehors de sa chaise que sur
sa chaise donc la dépouille qui jamais
aussi certains en place
alors donc du coup utilisé car elle est
à 5 foulée 3.622 des sims et f4 en fait
les dents ses positions les blancs
prennent le contrôle du centre
abc ce f4 light est joué donc les six f4
et en fait les noirs vont essayer de
taper sur le pion sur le plan c 4 on
crée vraiment le but on va dire de la
position n'en croyez tout ça c'est pas
te recommander parce que les normes pas
le centre on a un fou ans à 6,5 à
valeant à sac donc sur le côté je vais
boire mais bien sûr on la revoit donc du
coup il ya quand même des idées la
position
pour attaquer le pion c4 il ya plusieurs
idées la première déjà c'est de jouer
d'amd cette dame à 4 ça peut être une
idée a ajouté une attaque construction
c4 et l'autre idée c'est bien sûr une
veste c5
qui est intéressant
avec l'idée de ces cinq sais que je vais
à fixer on va dire la faiblesse qu'il a
fait de la faiblesse c'est
c'est le pion c4 donc je le fixe empêche
de bouger et après je mets une tour 11 6
8 est en fait sur collonges de menaces
de mange en d4 un joueur est le pion et
d'ouvrir à colonne c'est avec ma tour
sur le plan séquence montre à cette
thématique ses positions
nous c'est comme un cannois le pas mal
ça à l'époque il ya peut-être dix ans
quitter beaucoup vu dos avec des noirs
et ce genre de position avec nom qu'on
joue sur le court c4 donc on peut aussi
voir ce thème dans la roche au lit mot
pas mal de fois
où il ya un pion qui est faible mais
dans cette prison c'est un peu différent
parce que les blancs vraiment un centre
très très très fort que ce serait donc
par attention parce qu'entre deux
contres donc je pense que c'est une
position qui peut pas mal plaire avant
de foirest qui lui aime beaucoup je
l'initiative aime beaucoup attaqué et du
coup je sais pas ce qu'en pense amis
mais je moi je verrais bien un bon gros
et cela collait à guérir je pense quelle
position très intéressante
plutôt une référence pour les blondes au
genre de positions mais comme tu l'a
très bien expliqué le plan doit est
assez clair donc cette table sur ce
procès mais comment ça grimpe avec
beaucoup d espaces mais aussi la paire
de fou on va certainement faire le petit
roi qu'on avait été percé potentiel au
centre modèle ou pour ouvrir les fouet à
l'attaqué le roi s'il ya des noirs petit
rock position à trois résultats clermont
forest de plus par endroits on est ronde
on use je crois qu'il a duré cette
partie décisive sur 10 quelque chose
comme ça bien donc c'est spectacle
garanti quasiment chaque fois avec lui
il a perdu hier qui va avoir à coeur
peut-être de se refaire
il est passé sous la moyenne donc il
doit gagner pour revenir et si j'avais
si j'allais vendre forest bagheri au
niveau du placement là c'est sûr que 15
aides
grand pas vers la victoire mais je pense
qu'on va voir une partie de pêche aux
deux oui
c'est vrai que cette petite marche de
800 cas c'est tfc tu es war site
ils
paient
donc après par rapport à mon amant paris
avec avec kevin n'a évidemment je ne
suis pas pour vendre forest mais j'ai un
bon feeling pour lui dans cette partie
je pense qu'il
sait pas pour l'instant en plus tu vois
mes dernières il est bête au départage
iri france on tire il a vraiment à coeur
d'essayer de s'en faire et
[Musique]
vendre forest travaille pas mal avec dit
rien d'ailleurs dans les années
précédentes
cette année-là travailler avec arsène je
prends jeu en match plein du monde donc
je sais pas s'il travaille aussi avec
des ris encore ou pas mais mais en tout
cas c'est le les gens se connaissent
très bien et rassurant
mais savoir envoyer sur l'échiquier car
donc une bonne nouvelle d'ailleurs
certains ouvriers caf 3 et finalement
face aux aux changements de
set-up de geri n'a pas hésité à envoyer
avec quatre derrière joseph 4 2 temps
ouais
bah je pense pour attaquer à mon avis
dans les coins venir ça va être assez
assez violent ce qui va se passer donc
oui c'était une belle partie stouff
ouais ça va être encore une partie qui
va avec qui qui va bouger
alors enchaîné les
bras
ouais donc c'est quoi ces deux
mammadyarov mamediarov contre le kayak
et m'avait déjà robe signée carla qui
doit s'imposer il est encore un de ces
quatre ces parties blanches au 12e on va
voir sa
noble âge égal salaire bizarre comme
mais
j'ai pas fait attention
vous d'investir luthérienne qui sont
donné le mot et que carrasso aujourd'hui
sauf que il a choisi de jouer on va dire
que plus classique avec ses trois
carrières d'ailleurs je trouve il ya pas
mal de sport pendant la journée de repos
je reste passionné ça sur twitter
après ça nulle part contre quinssaines
en un quart d'heure donc moi la partie
la dernière partie il a commencé par
twitter cardiac kids
genre
faites et nuls pour stopper car c'est
notre absence était toujours là nul
qu'on khanaqinne il a mais un truc genre
un requin seigneur
karlsson 9 heures 9 heures 2009 sera
séquestré l'art comme ça et là il a
posté un tweet huile à ce crime
ce concept a fait exactement trois fois
la même nul avec les blancs mais c'était
dans des événements sur internet ça va
tu vois donc avec des enjeux qui n'a
rien à voir dans des rapides d'un cas
moi et ils inscrivent leur disant qu'ils
avaient appris du du meilleur du
champion du monde tu vois donc c'est
pour ça qu'il ait fait ça est derrière
il ya eu pas mal de réactions hostiles à
dire des gens pas de trois précieux son
manque de combativité l état notamment
très bizarre ce top ski salubre et à
jesse james key le président
de la fia de
la plana de la fidh s'est mieux
débrouillé il a je crois que je crois
qu'il est vice président tout comme ça
c'est il a plein de fonctions à la fille
de genre notamment le hanjin shipping
beaucoup beaucoup de choses c'est moche
et le nom du président de la
faf éliminé l'as est mort politiquement
un truc c'est exact il faut quelle façon
bref pour dire qu'elle suit hawks qui
donc qui est aux places et dans la ville
a répondu de caraquet dans un truc un
peu interdire quoi on lui dit fin c'est
très bizarre avec une telle position de
ba de décombres et la défense et
cardiaques est et du cougaing latine a
dit ok mais tu avais été plus fort que
moi quand j'avais 14 ans tu vois donc
j'avais 13 ans genre à 14,4 la john
paczkowski riscle et noir
ce qui est quand même au journal
nice-matin
match nul à 14 ans je te mettais déjà
fait celle
du rythme
bastos qui
il a même pas mal et 2007 à militer
c'est qu'elle a été champion d'europe
donc je sais pas moi même c'est un
joueur unique 6 en
2006 180 kwh pendant ses rangs un trait
là-dessus à présent
il ya beaucoup d'animations dernièrement
autour de cariane chaîne sur les réseaux
sociaux c'est pas l'unanimité lui même
alors qu'aujourd'hui
elle se fait surnommer du coup si le
ministre de la défense il le ministre de
la défense qui doit un peu plus lourd
répondre aux coups qui se prononcera sur
twitter notamment aujourd'hui donc là
les noirs là on est certainement le
meilleur c'est devant l'échiquier
justement
en défense et mon compte pour sa part de
tyrans qui va sûrement me donne lui
donner l'occasion de
peut-être de réagir puisque on a vu
qu'il allait attaquer l'avait dit rov on
s'est un petit peu ce pôle alors comment
d'en arriver là position avec chez
l'oréal est prise
à la jeunesse un coq et donc des cinq
sens normal en attaque le cavaliere d'un
média assez théorique elle aussi au sepa
ils perdent jouer au sahara haut niveau
donc les doigts réagissent en contre
attaquant sur le fond et fouillée ça que
tu aies jamais enregistrée peut-être on
peut montrer très vite qu'est ce qui se
passe sur
tous les théâtres mais en fait c'est
historique ça nous arrange et 7 et je
vois pour les élites le tireur est comme
suspendu dans
le même creuset froid
je crois que c'est ce que je vais partir
dont les dentistes un mois je vais
rentrer
le ballon rock et mange cavale et prend
environ 20 milliards d'animaux est
ce qu'on devrait accepter de jouer
pendant le jour de repos à place de
grille aux certainement mais en fait là
y'avait pas la position à guérir c'est
les organisateurs n'ont pas
décidé que dubaï il pouvait jouer s'il
ne voulait avec le basque et la refusez
donc tant pis pour lyon
c'est passé c'est à dire que dirait on
n'a même pas demandé on n'a pas demandé
son avis il a eu son point j'apprécie
bizarre hein d'échangés souvent c'est
parce qu'ils ont accepté en nombre et
sont mises ensemble
dans la tente il a même un premier test
est négatif mais c'était genre les tests
un peu fait vite il attend des résultats
du pc lequel puissance être plus fiable
et
ça prenait 24 heures de plus donc il
aurait pu jouer le jour du repos du
reste l'alternative qui pour moi avait
du sens en mai à son goût
c'était pas notre guerre belle la vie au
cinéma le
bof on a fait les frais donc oui on
revient par droit la partie donc à la
ligne logique j'ai ce cavalier une soupe
et
5,4 ou reprise
de 6
ça c'est hyper très rouge et 4h propre
synchro 3 on compte cinq lots en chasse
le fonds
concernés ici parce que la cause du coup
on a justement il payeurs avec même
parfois le seroc et donc la bataille
faisait rage quand vous voyagez cas ce
que j'ai 4 se trouve par contre c'est
l'artilleur
en fait les noirs veut le jeu f6
donc
qui ouvrirait l'agglo nef est cloué le
cavalier donc j'imagine que j'ai
400 da ok mais après moi je pense
conclut en effet ce week end
la vapeur
bailat je pense en fait ce qu'ils ont
comme m6 web 5 c'est la partie quand il
est passé alors est ce qu'il aurait dit
à prédiction est juste battre le mans
jean m6 en c6 et battre un cavalier en
route cinq
exactement
le cas c'est donc là on peut pas du tout
se permettre de perdre le plonger ce
serait catastrophique
on le roi blanc qui serait complètement
fou est
bon on prend au basson
baptista
visuellement avec les noirs derrière
cammas est content on finit
développement elle s'active alors
surveiller son destin avec à une pièce
tout simplement le cavalier froid qui
reprise bon c'est pas possible
c'est six importants pour pouvoir
contrôler en fait le cavalier le
cavaliere trois mois n'a pas de bonnes
cases seule pointe à ce qu'il a c'est
vraiment rendre cinq voix ont produit un
petit peu la position mais si on n'a
qu'à 25 mois de cavale est prononcé donc
du coup on va les mines et le cavalier
c6 pour un style qui avait des cours
d'allemand en ans le 5 et on l'a
contrait à tracer en plus qu'à valider
cette un jour
donc après 4,1 points à voir comme
pollution moi je moi je pense que que
une idée ça pourrait déjà euro à 2
2% levée du vis-à-vis que le fougueux 6
et peut-être un jour de cette ferme
france
f3 dans sa part est bizarre de f3 mais
en fait une fois que le cavalier water
en gérant se croient et bien le foot est
six fois plus trop venir sur la
déconnade genre 4 et le cavaliere en or
5 il est quand même très solide
personnes peu avant le coucher donc je
pense que c'est un truc qu'on pourra
voir en doublettes
les blancs ils veulent jouer sur la
porte c'est ce qu'avait alors qu'elle
vient d'installer une même pièce et
d'ailleurs
j'ai réfléchi
alors bon séjour à des rires et des
danses à trépas qu'à placer sur nous dès
lé départ à quel moment gâtés sur ebay
fr reste à quelques pratiques position
intéressante aussi avec la page de
l'athlétisme en de part et d'autre donc
faire on mais aussi peut-être en
échangera
à cette ordure en milieu de jeu
comment les noix est-ce que la d'image
mais c'est ça
une fourche à tourner cette sais pas si
c'est faisable
oui trois ans vivant chez ses parents
un calcul est suffisant je souffre je
sais pas si tu veux je te voit par là
bas j'ai parlé m'ont dit sors de ta
bouche
nous fait peut-être christophe barratier
d'un beau bluff c'est possible mais je
vois pas trop de retard je pense qu'il a
trouvé les chiens
ont bluffés ici la position aussi prêté
donc ça non plus dans les noirs qu'il a
un peu subi cette marianne
qu'est ce qui vous fascine tant famille
là oui je t'entends ok
to take a validé cette damage 4 c'était
ça pouvait être un peu merci c'est peut
être un petit peu un peu dangereux donc
j'aime pas sûr qu'on avait envie de
faire cavalier à dz je pense trouver le
joueur
pardon excusez moi on va pas d'un match
tout de suite tu as juste de parler de
second plan
puis après j'ai peur qu'à bâle et près
de quatre mois est-ce que vous ayez
décidé comme ça mais
c'est la partie est devenu
fou logique on peut dire que moi j'ai
deux alors moi j'ai deux rangées de huit
matchs joués cavale et j'espère que je
peux manger 5 séries charcutage à
l'utiliser excuse moi non non je ne
mange pas en danger le l'usiné
non je cours je préfère 4 derrière je
louche tout cas mamediarov il vient de
se rasseoir peut s'attendre à ce que je
t'aime pour moi je ne sais pas donc au
revoir à vis à vis à vis d'eux je serai
directement programme sepa aucun sens
est faible donc là pour le mieux les
cases
soja recrue
wade qui tient le 10 froid des yeux le
réveil est difficile falloir grand
traiteur la partie bonjour à ses risques
des fois que ça arrive pas si on
resterait pas là du coup
bah on n'est pas vraiment dans quoi moi
je crois de la farce puisque dans ma vie
et
chaleureusement par parfois de prépa
mais
ça peut des fois si vous attendez en
fait contre le joueur qui est trop bien
préparés quoi
une partie
iv c'était
on était
en serbie comme ça oui
aubrée novak
est
en fait celui là outre un gamin il était
champion notre pays et je suis pas ton
des rangs pour moi être il avait dit il
c'était en temps de crise de nombreuses
touches désolé
du coup
the way mais je joue et on était au parc
pour la servir dans un veut dire 1,3
pour les conditions étaient
catastrophiques
géraudel pire vous personne par les
anglais au cauchemar
la droite bien je perdais plein de
points et là je suis à parier contre un
gamin de 13 ans
qui faisait des caves et 2150 peut-être
mais qui avait une perte de 1400 qui
venait d'enchaîner les brosses les
grosses victoires et que tu es champion
de son pays je sais pas quoi donc pour
ça sentait pas très bon j'étais pas très
confiant quoi et en plus quand j'arrive
à la partie il me joue tous les coups
adamo est vraiment
un jeu je vois qu'il m'appelait de
bouffer il est rentré en fait les
allemands très paris il a un style manon
sa main il note son coup en jour là
tellement il y en a trop fait ramondou
de goutrens kitsch l'appui la n va au
wood regarde même pas ce que je fais
l'addition s'est rependue linotte et du
coup c'était d'espagnol donc un truc
classique mais le fond des 5 j'attaque
le fou avec bon pion et le font reculer
leurs attaques le fou elle était
tellement dense à préparer et par le
parti qui l'a pas oublié de recul à sion
de fo son fouquet dans des salles quand
tu as juste attaqué mon pions
elle a su pas pu aller voir son
septième quoique bon pion et on a
regardé
pertinente qu il a créé mot sur une
partie nord parce qu'elle était trop
dense à trépas il m'a regardé l'époque
les larmes aux yeux j'ai gagné en ti pou
le fou tour à tour gouverné par un
bullet des buteurs non mais il a donné
hier soir un coût mais fatigué il n'a
pas abandonné
et bien que la panne n'était pas du tout
j'ai déjà plein potentiel de plus et ça
va quoi
trop bas
[Musique]
c'était en 2000 e
serbie mais moi c'est la magnifique
halle centenaire petite taille tu le
regardes genre ma droite il me sera en
mode du coup il
me regarde ma porte sur elle ne mange
pas s'il te plait
merci tu le manges pas le fou pourrait
on dire 1 pour retomber dans sa prépa en
fait il y avait juste le coup suivant et
au pied d'occupation fou il a commencé
par me c3 c3 5 août ils vous de jouer
après quoi mais bon ça c'est une bonne
leçon pour les habitants il était jeune
et tu vois le fait de vraiment en mode
batch ou pas demain à rodez chaque étape
à porticcio dans la main les pièces dans
l'autre injuste à 1h40 pour jouer des
coudes que
j'ai en plus c'est bien que de masquer
aussi quand on aime séparer la f10 est
vraiment cherché préparation je l'aurais
siège pas un terrain abandonné pour
éviter de trouver un défoncé sur un truc
rêver laurentides ou même ça c'est pas
très bon en soi déjà
le
savez déjà deux bras croisés à se bâtir
l'image entre bab ezzouar free car il
est toujours bon ils sont pas contents
mais
il joue pas les erreurs ça c'est
de rappeler
quelques clics et angers sinon j'imagine
mal choqué quand j'ai su ce message
là carrément quoi juste pour montrer
très vite puisque alex me demandent
l'ouverture c'était
plus clair
c'est d'abord je veux plus ça joue bien
c'est d'abord que m6 punchy et
b52 grille était comme ça et avec son
stylo dans la vc3 il était en train de
noter
la partie il ya 250 ans
assez haut
comme ça en plus tu faisais coûteux
plaindre des textes de l'appariement
toujours contre un jeune de 13 ans ferme
à 2400 alors j'ai fait un mauvais
tournoi cette année noire tu sais qu'il
a se montrèrent avec lui qu'il est
préparé ou sur le papier était quand
même pas très heureux
tout y est vous avez battu rennes quand
m oui bin tué presque la fin de la
partie bah vite fait une enfilade ans
d'un coup un petit à -4 je me souviens
j'avais un gros plus ou moins pour boire
un coup mettez le qubit toute la partie
de quoi il parle il avait 25 25 50 c'est
mon premier grand maître queux terre
battue c'est quand c'est
non c'est pas communiquer là dessus
c'est bien mon tout premier c'était
l'adresse on arrive des grands maîtres
une premier but 25
je sais pas c'est possible mais j'avais
deux mille deux cents lots moi j'ai
battu à 25 50 et
et mais bon j'étais mal mal mal mal très
mal très mal très mal bon d'investir et
mais je me battrai corps et
propose des pièces chaque fois on fait
des émules
c'était un cryptage qui pourrait passer
en bullet joue un petit peu
énervant la porte le nom met d'accord
mais le mec en face
à niang louis
david
et quand je peux placer le fameux tour
en 16 ans qui viennent la pièce bas il a
tapé sont stables à truffaut
[Musique]
perdre jeu pac man où vous l'entendez je
pense aussi bien que moi est ce que tu
veux pas essayer de passe de payer en
pesos la la connexion mais le plus
accueillant parce que là ça devient
complexe et j'ai beaucoup
ouais ouais parce que par moment
malheureusement
la connexion schéma fait de cyann
c'était bien avant tiers d'avoir accès
heureusement instable
la charte qui traîne assez complexe on
va voir s'ils arrivent à payer mon poste
ouf je crois qu'il disait qu'on se
faisait attaquer par des chirons dans la
rue et c'est vrai que c'est ce qui se
passe et tu sortais pas c'est une toute
petite soeur de petits patelins servent
vraiment différent partout
c'était pas je pense qu'ils mangeaient
pas très souvent malheureusement l'epo
il s'était pas traire
pas très accueillant et pendant pendant
toutes ces histoires on a eu un premier
résultat déjà avec une lueur excuses ont
fait mieux que caraquet d'écart celle
d'ange l'impression d'une forte d'une
trentaine de minutes une deux nuls sur
pendante au dos d'âne c'est pas son
genre est ce que je sais pas avec les
blancs contre le semblant de plus dax
plutôt un très bon temps a
pas de gagnant pour lui de de recoller
un peu
mais alors tu peux me dire sur tweets
chaussettes violette c'était sur la page
d'accueil de jazz comme celle
là g pour toi
et ça rend pas les choses ça fait comme
moi peur que des gros chiens dans les
chais en plus de ben bella
alors voir comme très vite ça nul est
clair stouff pas si tu aimes tu
t'en ailles pas payé tous toujours je
m'entends
papa me tue sac ados veulent
pas partir impossible je vais
donc c'est le segment watch facebook
voilà ok on a eu un système de londres
de tout des champs que l'ong
et à
y accueillir des 5 il a proposé de bois
peut-être il a un problème parce que
c'est vraiment pas son genre elle
sentait pas très bien tati rapport avec
le contenu de celle je ne sais pas du
tout c'est avec le redoux dagg face à
des joueurs moins forts en ce moment
c'est pas trop -
très bizarre
voire peut-être jusqu'à la pause en un
gros quart d'heure et vous verra si ça
s'améliore ou pas de connexion mais ce
n'est pas le cas
pour essayer d'être délocalisé ses
cheveux
à rendre à l'amiable
ont lieu au québec un choix surprenant
to date on commande un serment d'
explication peut-être dans la soirée ed
une direction de poids 1 du coup ça fait
de partir - déjà aujourd'hui alors que
juste avec le forfait de
doolow est là pour l'anecdote j'ai aimé
ce silence est d'or mais je jouais
contraire du beauf c'était peut-être
at-il eu besoin de jouer un tournoi
comme celui et
commencé à s'embrouiller pendant la
partie parce que j'aurais voulu fait
tout alors que pour était pas sur cette
pièce est finalement excès des jeux
d'essai par signer la feuille gbagbo a
dû manquer mon fils tu as ça nous a
aidés non non c'est bon je fais forfait
et finalement ce matin que le brave
doivent former comme je sais pas si un
rapport jusque là ça va redonner des
pouvoirs le prémonition
mandela coincé dans sa l'avenir de
karachi
donc ça nous fait deux parties soit en
tout cas pour aujourd'hui
aduba rapport est donc déjà plus de 12 h
ans claude
voilà ce qu'on va voir la quatrième
partie qui est grande et youth et si
pencoo tout ça pour garder le meilleur
pour la fin c'est ce que j'étais surpris
en fait j'étais déjà prêt j'avais prévu
le clic sur alternantes dagerman a
rien de meilleur pour la fin la famille
et
oui c'est ça un an de retard
exactement qu'un set a déjà un pour
assurer pour la fin donc il avait déjà
remis points d'avance si gaga
aujourd'hui ça lui fera déjà deux sur
sur deux plus une partie avec les droits
contre qu'à moins d'un demain
s'il est aujourd'hui la casse et non
gagner le tournoi car c'est la partie
guérilla et trois sur trois jusqu'au
bout ça donc
on verra ça lui l'herbe à des ruches
c'est la mode et vous cela doit il écope
d'un michel lallier le test spsr
positive se battant pour tous peuvent
donc y aura plus les trois dernières
rondes là c'est indépendant de sa
volonté
la débâcle temps plein
alors tout [ __ ] en tenue sexy bègue
cobrandée s'affaisse la victoire épique
d'avant le genre de rebond justement
contre de pauvres peut-être que c'est
bien cet article a tonné le copilote du
beauf tellement c'est parce qu'il
importe quoi ça devait pas revenir
vers
lui après le toit ouais
il est même bien savoir
il a discuté de ça dans cet article il y
avait changé l'évaluation au moins
quatre ou cinq fois dans sa finale et
que oui il avait gardé de petit rappel
la partie il a décidé de changer là
parce qu'ils étaient mal autant sinon on
l'aurait perdu ce n'est pas chez
lui face chef est en très forte
récupération en fait moi je moi je pense
qu il était forfait
bain sans prévenir sachant que peu vrai
hello
par contre quand on est malade ou peux
tu peux ne cessent pas donc tu vois
quand tu vas dire
raison valable quand on chante et non en
ce que tu dois être bon le fait pas
alors là par exemple à hilla ville
alpine avec nous tu me salis toit
pour sa défaite contre kiri me pose la
question je sais pas parce que là ils
avaient fusé je ne sais pas exactement
pareil
peut-être gré des trois tiers monde
c'est sûr qu'il va pas perdre de poids
parce que voilà c'est à la fois mais
votre guide je suis pas sûr à 100 mais
je n'y a pas de permis
pas deux
en fait tu viens enfin tu perds des
points ou de fruits au moins la part de
tous et c'est bien dans les îles à
perdre jours qui font des forfaits et
des fois tu as envie d'aller jouer il ya
plein jour qui qui
perdent des ponts fin qui vont ils ont
fait don de sa et sap
et la wii devrait perdre des points pour
moi enfin si parlant avec sonb la main
sa faute si tu te bourrer la gueule papa
c'est ta faute tu es malade
j'ai en fait tu peux pas forcément
différent c'est ça le problème
depuis tu aura même une année
la perte du one node 2 devient sur l'app
store je pense
bah ouais on s'est posé la question on
est sûr très j'aurais témoin en fait
justement c'était juste retour avec les
blancs parce que les femmes sont sept
mois voire jude a rejoint chucho pour
regagner le tableau de la d2 dont ne se
rattraper et en plus il a voyagé pas 50
points à 12 de plus que jean claude ou
peu à part on a vu l'ouverture ensemble
a priori rien de spécial qui est pas de
raison il ya certainement il devait pas
se sentir bien ou enfin doit y avoir une
raison je pense qu extérieurs en tout
cas à l'échiquier pour qu'il fasse une
une courte sera sûrement peut-être dans
l'article si vous lisez après les
articles chaise comme qui sont aussi
traduits en français vous pouvez lire
ensemble et le soir au fond c'est le
lendemain avec des analyses des parties
des réactions des joueurs explications
certainement on en sera plus de
7000 éclair de deux guitares
alors grand défi c'est sa peine comme ce
coup l'espagnol ce qui va la voir alors
on va voir est-ce que ce qui va reculer
fou sur des cinq grandes hélices est
beaucoup plus fort que le petit serbes
battent conte ce 3 2 et 3
il a vu la menace fauves et trois ans de
privation
vers ce qu'elle change de suivre cette
voie
cela ne peut pas être venu en est qui
qui traduit la grosse majorité de ces
articles du tata steel 2 au coeur je
confirme débats parfois sur le titre
open où est ce que tu aimes évidemment
j'aime les pièces noires leur toit
j'ai trouvé ça plus en plus place
les noirs sont mieux passées j'ai un
petit peu de beurre à la va-vite quoi
voit la pub n'a pas la même sensibilité
patates et en juniors
beaucoup
d'annoncés marshall à gages croise tout
va
ouais sont à vue des trois
matchs à détroit
les grandes manoeuvres cette position on
a déjà vu des tarés des tops de voix
et le fameux t4 ont les blancs j'ai déjà
joué ça aussi un cadeau genre fois
je crois qu'il a déjà conclu martin ici
au pas empêché le courage qui qui
pourrait vraiment gêner les blues chez
vega
lannoy ici dans une posture il n'aime
pas échanger pour l'instant il préfère
maintenir le statu quo moi bah justement
pour garder ou sur un rapport de force
équilibrés donc si une telle
démonstration un petit peu varié rêve
mais ce n'est pas encore une grande
ouverte m voici plutôt légèrement mieux
pour les blancs tiago qui devrait
comprendre des rayons x à le pion le soc
est sous pression
et il a fait le choix direct de faire
des grandes réussites des cinq
coups à la place de sa série la spa oui
pertes mater qui est pop condé
il se trouve cependant et
ou après plus tard quatre cavaliers sont
des ceintures en cavalier de saint béat
gym douce et ouais ipad est propre on y
aura plus passe t on mais qui après un
petit peu mais en plus cette idée avec
point qui
fait d'abord faut pouvoir prouver que
payant 25 mai
d'amsterdam
700 un grand coup et donc des cinq là
c'est hyperimportant fait regardez là
j'ai tout de suite qu'avaliser 4 si bien
qu'au et s'il n'est pas fait pour se
mettre l'arrière dans une partie lente
et en luttant contre les maîtres
international pascal chaumeil qui leur
demandait s'ils font c'est peut-être que
certains d'entre vous ont déjà deux
connaissent
j'avais pas justement ramener mon
cavalier position de juste en jeu je
sais pas j'ai fait jouer au ballon mais
admettons h6 ou faux bessette est en
fait après b3 le canadien devient
extrêmement mauvais mais ça devient même
dramatique on trouve aucun chemin pour
le recyclage des gaz en fait sont
contrôlés et j'avais joué toute la
partie avec ses cavaliers en moins
quelques est vraiment saharien de taxis
g7 jouer ses cadres pour avoir la casse
ces sacs abandonnés y aura des cartes
pour ferme elle est donc il vraiment
hors jeu et il a aucun moyen de se
redéployer même en sautant de partout y
a juste pas de place c'est pour ça que
c'est hyper important dans une position
de jouer karine ses cannes tout de suite
pour sûr b3 c'est la partie pouvoir
revenir en b6 et maintenant vas il a des
schémas ou bien pouvoir revenir là c'est
ce cavalier va s'échanger de revenir on
web 6 et il sera dangereux dans la
partie ça c'est vraiment très martyrs
dans cette variable de l'espagnol pas se
faire piéger ce cavalier
et oui effectivement michel reeber je
sais pas si si j'vous s'il entraîne
encore longtemps j'ai pas vu sur l'eau
c'est possible à vos clubs d'échecs le
bois colombes en région parisienne ou 8
jenlain
[Musique]
17 tables 2 et au nom d'el hadj omar
donne une espagnole c'est typique juste
avec le joie qui est finalement pas si
on voit pas si souvent c'est arrêter de
fermer aussi vite le centre en ce moment
les blancs 27 d'intentions plus
longtemps
ouais ouais mais elle redescend que
c'est un coût qui empêche roi toutes les
heures
l'erreur car il a souvent
pourvus de foule et futurs on supprime 1
donc des cinq mois s'écoulent j'aime
bien faire si on
regarde confirme également possibilité
pour des 1/4 et lille les deux cas mais
l'élève travaille j'ai trois mois une
position qui vous promettre
c'est une espagnole 1 1 mais qui
transpose dans une bande qui a exposé
lors de la cécilienne avec un moment
donné et on s'est tu
[Musique]
c'est parce que tu veux cherche
exactement mais en fait non mais c'est
pas toi c'est connu on atteindra michael
espagnole avait estimé
alors battez vous savez c'est bizarre il
meilleur rendement que
travaux qui ne pas placer dans ta
question je sais pas si tu passes et de
la poser de manière détournée ou
différemment et cei
a moins perdu 4 1
du coup on a encore un petit prix
et sous la pluie s'arrête pas ce soir on
verra pendant la pause peut-être te
connecter à
internet pour un cerveau cheveux non
mais ça va enfin celles ci sont pas
seulement
parce que je change quelque chose change
d'endroit ok
c'est qu'elle assez complexe
petit prodige qui reste sur une victoire
estime être en confiance et un quart à
draka de victoires 2 défaites car commis
une gaffe contre rapport justement être
l'ombre de lui même ces derniers temps
c'est pas gagné mais en profiter ça
reste pourquoi à ce qu'un peu trop haut
pour lui à sa victoire d'ailleurs
contrat c'était sa deuxième plus grosse
victoire de sa jeune carrière à prague
jusqu alors qu'à l'est pas du tout par
l'offre à gibraltar gros
voilà karana serait encore plus beau
plus calme donc on va voir ça
à 4 qui joue à 5 à tout ça donne la casa
des gardiens ça fait le trou donc c'est
un coup à se faire
violence juste pour gagner quatre pieds
du lit à sac
je viens des questions bientôt
belle adresse à pied 6 6
1 6 2
et tout début donc on va bientôt voir
peut-être franck le 4
août peut-être voir une répétition ça me
ferait cavalier à deux
comme ça
sans rien lui en fait cavalier à deux
pour gagner la part de tous vraiment tu
peux pas trop trop de mal et rien de
plus terrible donc c'est bhaskaran un
compte le faire ou pas et la food & 6 il
offre 4
et
5 mai après sera isolé ou manger des
cinq peut-être où on peut donc c'est
possible qu'il est bon tout ça après
être arrivé quand même là on en a parlé
l'autre jour et je comprends bien
meilleur que lui mais bon l'huile à
l'eau c'est pourquoi comme ça sans
couture ce qu'il veut c'est rester et je
suppose à
[Musique]
motoriser
amadeus
dupont maintient qu'elle est au niveau
et on a je me sens important mais
quelque 1400 film kick ass off line
hockey parce que nous sommes capables au
gabon mais il a quand même vieillissant
pour l'époque c'était extraordinaire
honnêtement mais voilà il a beaucoup
d'années donc au qui lave sa vie a fait
ça dépend je sais par ici pour quelles
raisons êtes un conseil ce bouquin quel
est ce que c'était pourtant il est plus
à se rattacher la tactique puisqu'il ya
des choses la plus spécifique pour la
tactique par exemple la tactique we can
qui
s'est très souvent recommandé notamment
par an par cavia aussi par marvel un
pareil 180 ch et qui sera livré quelques
vraiment bien
ouah stratégiste ouf c'est dire tu sais
ce que tu parlais de temps avant terme
en a parlé c'est délicat
je viens de l'écrire le chat alors il a
poussé une bouche à sur l'échiquier
moquer ouais très bon bouquin se sait
plus trop sur la large stratégie
dynamique voire holding sas complètent
très bien avec de telles tactiques aux
arcanes du co ouais c'est pas tactique
c'est plus dans la dans la stratégie -
ya un peu de tout ça c'est complet c'est
pas mal à se voir reconnu au sens
français du ciment chance et sa sonnerie
les perspectives
d'accord d'accord s'il vient aussi c'est
pas mal
oui s'ils battent les maths cilman ça
reste toujours notre récit beaucoup mais
ça reste toujours de la carence en vrai
je n'ai pas à lui personnellement j'ai
pas forcément vu d'élèves qui l'avait
ancien libraire mai
mais bon j'ai déposé co2 temps de ciment
oui et non c'est je pense que c'est bien
aussi le conseil d'état de michel
où
on va peut-être partir oppose alors
valoir à bord d'un petit parc andria ah
oui comme ça me convient on avait
presque oublié qui est en train de
vraiment
rentrer dans son tournoi il a gagné sa
première partie il a fallu la mort le
jour de repos aussi avec les doigts et
leila les plans contre le jeune belge
daniel dare dare à long terme des lots
liste dans la dette ce faire donc
c'est une bonne opportunité pour
marc-andré hyères var après
que des
noms l'aref charcute inquiète
alors il a opté pour
une buse eau qui est fou g5 chine
a je suis pas manquer bons
souvenirs m'ont dit bravo elle est belle
et bt cette crise crise
de foi du classique
et c'est ce à quoi tu es software avant
le jour du repos un marteau réa qui a
joué avec et noir avec plus isoler cette
partie pourrait se retrouver contrôler
le tir hoc saison 7 une fois cuit aubrac
terrier n'est plus cloud est donc seul
coup se retrouvent à
manta curie se jouer tard en rupture
isolée stouff jeu c'est clair c'est
normal en fait de ses positions en fait
là il va jouer donc probablement fou au
c-2
contre leucate et là on va voir contre
comme damas cinq
se dit qu'on pouvait notamment des jeux
des clous est inquiète pour ce 3 et
mettre une tour en 1 8 et 1 caballé en
quatre séries par logique dé vraiment
c'est d'attaquer le pion de 7,3 donc à
d'autres manières de quoi faire ça des
fois avec avaler les six foulées sept
cavaliers à 4 et nos possibilités pour
aller manger le pion à 4 à lui que ce
soit pendant en fait ça ressemble
beaucoup à une position de la rade
ouazine qui connut avec vos pensées 3 ou
en fait et en option ces trois il est un
peu faible et on a une majorité on a
trois contre un autre trois contes de on
a sept bessède ses 4 à 3 à 2 3 donc dans
le futur peut-être pousser les pions
essaie de créer un pont passé et pendant
ce temps là les blancs vont jouer avec
avons essayé de jouer avec 4 dont 3
défendre le pion depuis un an ne
laissera donc plus qu'à valider 2 faesch
échange un plan en quatre jeux f34 et
c'est de jouer comme ça me kaeppelin pas
par là
donc là c'est pas vrai la pollution
est perdu les idées sont à peu près des
mêmes la france
je suis hôtesse d'entre eux
marc andrieu on va voir comment ça
évolue ah ok
ok ok vous reste à faire mais
mais ça va jouer des deux côtés je sais
qu'il a une arme de poing de 56 minutes
donc ça c'est quand même encourageant et
notamment dans sa première moitié de
tournoi ça se passait très rare il était
toujours à travers l'otan aussi et dans
les dernières parties justement bagnols
si un peu du poil de la bête à la pendue
de la confiance dont l'impression que
c'est tout et c'est plutôt bon signe à
voir mais là et là on voit derrière
darda à lui conçu pas pu donc l'unocam
vachement gendarmes
autant donc peut-être une partie sous
payés et que là d'un pas bien quoi
baisse
c'est beaucoup et d'avoir dépensé à
trois quarts d'heure de
10 coups dans cette position en plus qui
est pas non plus
à quai à cette théorie qu'en fait je
pense
retrouver
après la pause
dans quelques minutes je sais pas ce
qu'on va faire du stuff je vais décider
on va voir on discutait à ses débuts
pendant cinq minutes et j'ai reçu je
sais pas un peu plus a tout de suite
[Musique]
il
e
oh
[Musique]
là
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bon
où
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je suis de retour se trouve devrait pas
trop tarder elle
vous est toujours avec nous
c'est magnifique musique pendant le jeu
et on est de retour avec la partie de
magnus carlsen donc on vous rappelle qu'
aujourd'hui la sueur peut-être de faire
le trou en vue de son point bonus qui va
arriver lors de la dernière ronde on
avait laissé les deux joueurs entrés
joue contre philipp lahm ans dans les
tous premiers gros sur cette italienne
on veut dire très basique en tout cas en
termes de développement et visites après
réflexion a choisi de jouer ici à
schiste un
choix bien sûr qu'il ya du sang cents
par rapport à la can g5 qui peut être
embêtant dans dans plusieurs ligues
notamment après le petit rock
car ça ne l'a répondu par la symétrie
avec h3 et dans ces deux ouvertures
aussi parfois un petit jeu un peu de
regards on doit attendre que l'eau 3
potentiellement l'attaqué parce que si
on reçoit mon premier bain du qu'on
donne son adresse ans et demandera le
ballon renvoyé par exemple le projet
donc c'est aussi pour ça que des petits
coups d'attentes profil active à vous
allez voir il a fait les oreilles
d'altitude comme on dire
la solution s'il veut garder son fou
et qu'intel lui il a des oreilles d'âne
aussi mais pas symétriques puisqu'il
envoyé pion à quatre avec un peu les
mêmes idées mais ils font plus d espace
aleida
10 6 a été jouée fouet 3
c'est le cri sur un petit peu classique
l'eau s'ils
acceptent de se doubler les pions mais
l'idée lancée la partie c'est que l'on
crée quand même un petit équilibre on
ouvre la colonne f on va jouer aussi
pour le centre d'instruction repris vers
le sont donc c'est un soutien au
décathlon
et
vous et si c'est elle je pars vite et
donc
pas encore une fois c'est un peu le
miroir
mais cette fois-ci 47 dérouleront à
semer très décidé de ne pas manger mais
plutôt de protéger
je vois intéressant par bale 3 en disant
si tu manges j'ai bien sûr prendre comme
ça pour créer un des deux centres
dans la colonne mais aussi pour 20 tours
et peut-être à terme je vais des quatre
jours le tirage aurait la colonne f
aucune position et quand les fouilles
ont disparu de l'échiquier il ya
plusieurs parties dont se tendra comme
ça tu aimes on regarde les chevaux
et intéressante
visite d'un pape christofi l'invs auquel
william après celle ci oppose deux jours
il pourra et je pense qu'elle pas
forcément sur d'intérêt moi je pense
qu'au match de vidic car j'aime doit
attendre que une wii vous cavaliers à 5
pour forcer défendre
peut-être pas forcément échanger
lecavalier
ouais on verra des 5 à partir de 2,5 à
partir et très naturelle comme réaction
centrale mais s'affaiblit aussi un peu
pour ça qu'il faut faire attention
car ça n'a pris
la parole tout échange est
prometteur on vois pas de quel amour de
lait blanc serait mieux ici pourquoi et
à la colonne est sa part et
montage en fait ce que je recherche
c'est un il est je pense qu'il
rechargement des positions qui sont
un petit plus visités ou bien il ya un
enjeu là tu vois là trop de place au
doute le pion elle est vraiment
différente il ya les polonaises pour les
blancs ouverte hunt et pour les noir et
en fait ils firent une composition où il
ya un peu des différences a donc là où
il peut essayer de jouer aux dames des
six est bien car ça fait il est vrai
labrecque physiquement je pense
justement créé un peu de deux dvd
barbers thèse procès de la dame ceci dit
je ne sais pas
il y avait tablé venu défendre
ok donc qu'est-ce qu'on peut accomplir
regarde je sais pas doubler les tours
vitrées casef c'est
bon c'est vrai beau
il a pas gagné je veux dire cette partie
supposée à 15h25 jusqu'ici tout sept
huit ans avec les blues fois qu'ils
baissent et victoire au général dans ce
tournoi il les a acquises assez
facilement jamais on n'a jamais eu à
dépasser leur ajoutant moi pour gagner
mais ce concept est décédé aujourd'hui
25 ans 30e coup là le type de position a
priori savoir une position longtemps
donc avec un micro plus
hauts du long terme
vinci a pas tant que ça
j'y répondrai sûrement avoir
curieusement cette question
beauvois curieux et pc
sais pas ce qu'il va faire de très bons
donc là un petit peu de jeu beaucoup
beaucoup de choses un coucou ne verra
probablement passer aux 4 je suis en
fait le plus gros gain pas mal de gaz
pour l'instant c'est la case droit voilà
non peut-être 1 3 ou 1 to rêve de points
qu'une autre tour f1 ou peut-être un
cavalier 2 qui leur pose avec camaïeu 4
plein de coups comme ça qu'ils sont qui
sont possibles cavaliers h4 aussi vous
prend 1,6 je le vois pas mon instant
rien de forcer ses joueurs venant de
bégoux
ça paraît pas
hyper ambitieux et surtout par apple sur
non plus
ah oui effectivement c'est une question
de me mouiller là
je te répond déjà ta sont des gens
regardent le candidat est donc
ou par la force des choses j'aime
vraiment beaucoup les analystes de
mathieu cornette qu'il est vraiment
vraiment passionné a en fait il transmet
sa quand il commente on sent qu'il a
l'amour du jeu et j'ai pour ça que c'est
vraiment chouette à regarder c'est ça
transpire de chacune de ses
interventions de ses idées il a envie de
montrer tout ce qu'il a vu et
c'est vraiment très agréable de regarder
les analyses de mathieu et il ya des
bases a évidemment très très fort grand
maître
mais du coup j'ai très très peu le
regard des deux ne vais pas trop
d'expérience pour
mon avis est comparé de toute façon il
ya vos fondations pour tous les goûts
mais elle sait pas que wahba dieu c'est
vraiment un des joueurs que je préfère
regarder commenté
je pense que tu partages d'ailleurs
d'avis et je crois savoir
complètement bêtement
mois qu'on remette world georges très
bien en plus un ami et est du coup
à il est amoureux d'une chute et du
pouce et c'est enfin pouvoir devancer
vidéo d'après m c'est un 5e reggae celle
jadis un jeu leur jeu j'en ai tenu que
je regarde matthew pas
pour des échecs en fait on a
l'impression que mathieu c'est chez qui
c'est le publie des vidéos pour les
cours ben tu sens qu'il a vraiment
illégal le fait vraiment ce que bill
gates voilà c'est clair et bah il est il
et
il est pas là et des fins c'est
trimestre commente avec elle en ce
moment mais c'est un peu dommage nous
aussi on prend même pas parce qu'on
prend on va le voir c'est ça fait
drôle avec les amis il ya quelques jours
en stream c'est qu'en fait nous mêmes
amalgames book mathieu décombe à
l'occasion riba au monde en même temps
est bon on ne peut pas le faire ou en
fait
c soulignée de 6 c'est se mettre un peu
à moi je pense c'est ce qu'on essaie
aussi de faire au niveau soit
intelligiblement tout le monde en fait
parce que si on est là pour débiter
montré des dents d'ordinateurs mais sans
s'en explique éric soit abordable face
les 2500 n'ont pas besoin de nous
regarder les parties est donc il décide
de s'adresser au public à moi par mes
coups avec les échanges de plus dans la
pédagogie en tout cas que dans la
complexité absolument
dix mois la vie
ou à voir en tout cas ce que ce que fait
ce que fait magnus c'est un moment
charnière de la partie comme on l'a
montré il a il ya quand même plusieurs
plans
alors sa vie on va le voir à cabral et
ben il va jouer mon petit favori j'étais
chaud pour qualité de ce thème au vu des
premières on répète ce cavalier sur
cette belle carte de 4
libéré aussi la colère des poulets tour
blanche
peut-être un jour en fait je peux aussi
maintenant menacé de reprendre le
cavalier on sait qu'un échange pour
pressuriser l5 a juste pour montrer voix
y avoir une vraie pression du sursaut
ça peut aussi être intéressant
tout cas je pense qu'on aurait une
partie assez bon aujourd'hui
vite il va devoir je vous rends fou de
cours et résister peut-être à la
pression sur le long terme de 15 7 bat
pas face à la caméra
filme et
d'une presse a beaucoup
apprécié même par un praticien
à une équipe sait qu'il va pas de nulle
part
et
voilà exemple qama du lukka cobas et
déjà en principe à cette évidence là
parce que la souffrance et en prendre
six canale 5 et quand d ailleurs et sous
cette année parce que c'est peut-être
une journée la journée des nuls c'est
quoi une deuxième de la rapide entre
babadjanian
à plus long terme en chantier
et ouais c'est sûr que sir michel la
vidéo de les analyses de blattes
évidemment au passé notamment une vidéo
de clips ferme qu'elle vienne pendant là
pendant le championnat du monde et vous
avez appris beaucoup de choses c'était
assez ouvert
mais déjà quelles que soient mes longs
attentats font des trucs
il est allé voir autres et réalisme la
dépendance et les championnats du monde
ce serait incroyable
alors au modèle une officier c'est la
mort d'un petit peu déçu parce que cette
partie est nouvelle fois battre à
l'animation de l'ouverture et puis c'est
à petit
on peut battre les gants devant moi ils
sortent d'un joueur de kayak et je pense
que ça devrait aller la venue lors d'un
quart d'heure jours de repos derrière
trois jours au dessus de cas c'est bon
ça va
ap me magnan fossiles aventure il avait
le contemplant sa petite règlement non
plus voyez-vous barça 3-1 aux
particuliers tasser les 13 route c'est
beaucoup sont des joueurs n'a plus
vraiment d'ambitions de gagner le
tournoi
vu le programme allégo va ça perd un
peuple aussi les joueurs ont beaucoup de
parties à l'ets grande richie arrive
pour réduire son important c'est de se
qualifier pour les candidats pour karen
génial candidats donc c'est vrai que bon
ça votre tournoi mais de là à avoir se
dépouiller
bad apparemment d'ailleurs pas qu'ils ne
franchissent pas et peut comprendre est
mon vieux le calendrier est très chargé
mais aussi
après peut-être une juste ni de m'avait
terreur latente et et ça arrive souvent
c'est en fait deux voyages à lui rappelé
que les blancs ils ont une idée réside
pas au pire avec les doigts il va bien
que kodak il va savoir ce qu'il pouvait
faire il va sortir de sa bulle et dans
le cas où il n'est pas très grand sur
cette ligne là je vais pouvoir que
savoir davantage et il se dit bon bah
tête quand je pense à 10 fois je ne sais
pas quatre fois je mets pour le galsi
fois ça va faire deux tant pis pour les
fois où ça va faire 1 2 vite c'est
vraiment comme ça que ça marche à ce
niveau là je pense tout le
jeu le bain et donc peut-être que là
dans ce cas de figure la route à fait
possible
et la pression comme ça tu couvres
avec harcèlement sur sur la dame l'idée
du coup c'est quoi pourquoi il un projet
de l'ars et c'est bon peut-être que ça
c'est pas si facile pas les connaître
dabbachi qui a fui dans leurs tours 7
c'était peut-être quelque chose si tu
connaissais pas ça peut-être qu'elle
s'était mal avec les noirs en fait mais
qu'arrive t il à trouver mais je pense
que leur analyse un escalier là pas de
case en faty obligé de venir ici ah oui
alors deux fois
web est
impressionnant et ouvert et père de fou
a cessé sa peur c'est prometteur pour
les blancs parce que là où pire des cas
je mens je vais m'en veux être moi je
mange quand il y aura le radar pour 900
euros
c'est pour ça que c'est jouable
mais bon c'est pas c'est parce que tu
veux avec les blancs et orange
dans les profondeurs
lieu
une nulle ah ben moi j'aime le côté très
sympa et très sympa parité avec chasse
comme avoir bien lu partir dans les deux
professeurs
alors
qui va les voir se trouve du coup ça
nous limite de la ruhr est parti non je
trouve qu'on aille voir 20-13 grille
parce que
il s'est passé plein de choses et on
avait à peu près annoncé le plan de noir
contre c'est pourtant tout s'est passé
comme ça
parce qu'on avait dix ans est remonté à
des six f4
on en était là donc ça veut dire cette
liste elle habite on l'avait dit que
damas quatre était un thème pour
attaquer le pion à 4 et qui avait aussi
une autre idée de ces cinq pour s'éviter
de la colonne c'est pour attaquer le
pion de c4 qui est la faiblesse chez les
blancs donc avait des trois cavaliers de
snow gîte et 6,25 qui obtient court
aussi un peu logique parce qu'en fait
2,5 premièrement ça bloque le pion et 4
donc ça empêche les blancs de faire eux
même sac et aussi ça bloque le pion aux
4es du coup le foot est roi et bien lui
il devient un petit peu
pas très bons donc par contre le pion de
4 il est en prison pendant le pion à 5
par an il a reprises deux fois alors en
cas de capture deux fois et ben je mange
mange mange et joue qu'à valider cet a
priori et je récupérerai le pion 25 avec
lecavalier et la scrute les blancs sont
quand même très très moche ça serait
catastrophique pour les blu
autant parfois les pions doublé peuvent
être pas mauvais votants ici
on
se faire ils vont se faire manger les
arbres et les autres ça fait d'être
efficace pour les halls et caves
à voir donc encore c'est pas une option
envisageable est envisagée par brest pas
du tout je mets ça arrive d'amour
laroquais
plus logique façon il sait que il est
prêt à reprendre dans les deux cas
rock of ages aussi chez les noirs
maintenant il la triperie ce qui a du
sens pour ouvrir la colonne f
et là je vous imagine que il doit
peut-être calculer des choses comme
peut-être tout reprend f6
alaska
c'est
un sacrifice qui peut avoir lieu de
dames g4 et chaque roi à chute d'un
match 4l en bêta pour les noirs 1 il
peut y avoir des nullards à l'asile
quand j'étais à dire où vas tu t'amuses
est bien dans la colère c'est cool quoi
c'est thorax bataille je vais te battais
quoi je me demande si tu veux même tour
orateurs et om je l'espère vers
le n'a pas compris les échecs quoi
le fait de voir que
eux
le fait de voir que tout est noir sans
l'aide de dame bogdan balan mais d'un
côté qui assamoi s'entendent très active
madame
ça va vite
mais
mais oui d'alger qu'a prise la nation
contre je sois la rochelle
salle à manger de choses mais
va venir
matt moore est pas là je fais pas payer
trop cher ce n'est qu'à la trop moche
charte des douches
ce que dame j'ai quand même avancer que
forte dois-je aura vu que sur 8 bureaux
à ce rythme on aide les noirs dans la
f1 la
dame f1 se défend ses quatre jeux
suivants la d1 et je me demandais si
intéressant
s'il est juste et c'est
trois quatre ans j'ai un petit peu de
rhum
je suis bien d'accord que tu as du jeu
il a très intéressant ces sacrifices
mais en tout cas je pense que c'est ce
qui me regardait alors jouer je ne sais
pas
cela dépend de ce qui va voir mais on a
un coût ils doivent ou confédération
barça
c'est quand tu vois le glissement annuel
dame
ouais si on vraiment intéressante
auraient pu s'ils étaient fermés est ce
que vous mangez maintenant ça pour avoir
du sens
et oui c'est un moteur n'a pas le temps
de par exemple ouvrir un se fout
on pensé attaquer les cases blanches
avait trop long on va se faire bloquer
donc c'est toujours une option ferme à
ici ça peut être possible en disant
ouais c'est de fermer son pour attaquer
les tranquillement pendant votre temps
elle ramènera kembs nos pièces qui sont
ligotées la défense de ce pion
la sueur des cuvées d'études sommes des
capitaines 7 15 oui mais aussi question
des 500 km à l'est
pas ce que tu en penses tu es sa cavale
de huit
et ayant des 6 et je te bouffe ses
cadres et bon courage ça va je crois que
t max 500 comptait 4 toi
moi je sais pas comment on peut être
faire un coup comme tours fc aussi si on
sacrifier bas si on veut préparer
mais une pression et on prépare
peut-être un doublage si tu veux en voir
une tour qui arrive aussi par là
et si vous voulez voir s'ils ont tous je
pense qu'on a du mal à l'exception de
ces cas
la position très intéressante j'aime
bien pour problème si c'est autant après
faut quand même trouver une continuation
il n'est pas moi votre forêt cela arrive
vraiment à s'activer à faire participer
ses gestes très très mal se passer
progrès qui est assez courageux leurs
dettes rentrer là dedans
10 mn sur le pion sekkaki si le mot jeu
pourrait provoquer des échanges massif
et soulager un petit peu du coup les
dangers sur son droit à venir mais la
position la plus intéressante
moi j'aime mettre des beaux jours
c'est parce qu'on change
du coup va au caire pour ton avis de
flèches et 47 juste pour
augmenté de
10,2 elles sont ok
[Musique]
un coup qui a du sens mais qui est
responsable pour la classe de 4e
cavalier mais on s'habillait un petit
peu sur quatre branches
bon ben ça c'est vraiment fou aux stars
candidat c'est assez logique finalement
et les doigts il peut même bien bon bah
moi je suis très bon en 07 pendant cet
espace
a bien que c'était comme un coup aux
deux est partie que l'emballage un fond
on sait qu'après le groupe souffre du
mal
comme tu le voulais
donc c'est quand même
très judicieux n'aime pas non plus subir
de manière trop passive on l'a vu à la
partie contre du golfe qu'il a gagné il
n'a pas hésité tel est le fil tous les
risques il avait envoyé ces jours où il
avait son roi bayane mbia l'échiquier on
n'est pas un petit banc
et puis regardez votre tag avant-hier il
est perdu
est ce qu'un comme à peut-être peut-être
un peu de matches
les quatre escrocs cible des 4 b une
madame
coeur
de cette ferme et 5 et même dame b
alors bouquin howard si je pense que les
deux sont complémentaires clairement
amadeus
a de la difficulté sur ordinateur c'est
que tu as énormément de ressources donc
c'est dur d'y voir clair de savoir quoi
choisir et tac avec des vidéos qui
seront très bien des répertoires facile
des vidéos et du taux sur les finales il
ya plein de jeunes aux biens
c'est un côté bien sûr lui 10 po sie et
attraits les gains du plus souvent vous
sert un peu plus en profondeur en fait
je que les vidéos c'est bien pour ce ils
vont sentir délai pour faire des
détectives des choses et ça va vite quoi
et pour aborder la surface a fait je
peux me faisait davantage de voix il est
libre mais là pour avoir une autre
version aussi de prendre sont venus
prendre sur l'échiquier et jouer les
poux et servat
[Musique]
carton il est où le chômage est sur b4
c'est de dire bien plus abordable
ce serait si on surcharge avec des fours
de pièces à la fois
et si on déclare bien sûr il ya le fou
qui est perdue sur échec et c'est les
noirs de commencer par se soulager de la
tension entre les faut on peut prendre
sur échec et après on pourra
anciennement faire ce contexte plombé le
défendant l'avant-scène 21 unités
ouais non plus aussi
adam b3 avec les blancs pour provoquer
un effet vous et surtout conquérant
j'aurai les poumons
mais après mes quatre et un salaire un
petit peu un peu tard aussi donc que ces
parcours passait pas
la pression sur neuf mois
papa tu crois que de l'espace
allèles da je pense à couper dans le
dans le piège de champion du monde un
fois d'autres puisque sèchement l'arcade
un peu plus limité maintenant il peut
scier de complétion à cologne et beau
pays peut manger mais payant c4 du bas à
voir comment
je vois pas trop
c'est de
changer la structure
après je sais on vous rappelle que
comme ou sans ordinateur et avec notre
et est donc tout et c'est pas évident
pour nous et mais après c'est en
essayant vous montrer un peu comment
nous on réfléchit et on l'écouté ou non
on n'est pas sûr à lire leurs ventes
d'apple lire une c est pas facile et où
met on pas comme ça
de nous faire
rire comme nous donc la b4 mal à un coût
humain ouais mais n'a sciemment et 3 et
on profite du fait qu'il ya un problème
sur le fouet qui échec au 6 mai pour
lever 5
intéressant d'avoir le choix que fait
qu'un set au passage bienvenue à toi tu
bros et bah du coup on va suivre
ce que tu le dit et on va aller jeter un
oeil à la partie de gants des lieux
peut-être toute façon maintenant
d'autres seul tour des échiquiers est
plus restreint ne reste que 4
avec une position que nous dit
prometteuse poids pour les blancs avec
un f4 amené à revoir son ensemble on
était restés ou stouff précède pas deux
espagnols j'explique et l hyper
important de jeu guèye seck a tout de
suite pour ne pas se faire piéger ce
cavalier
il aurait vraiment aucun n'a rien aucune
case et garçons contrôlé
alors été là il était retombé 6
cd cette position fermée
et cavaliers pour leucate souffre waouh
alors il est vrai qu est ce qu il a
préparé sa harley avis est d'inspiration
d'avoir l'échiquier
on a vu qu'il ya une heure à la pendule
je pense qu'il a dû trouver en reste et
on valoir au sort donc sacrifier une
pièce s'adresse pas aux pseudo sacrifice
a priori il n'y a pas la récupérer
c'est de gagner les jo ou centraux et
prendre vachon le centre et ses propres
options sa part été sauvé mais très
intéressant elles sont suivies
accor et vend la pièce
parce que surtout ses deux skis se passe
pas sur fous ces deux
jusqu'à vallier pendant y avait vraiment
des provocations dandy mais brillante
pour la sexuation
auxquelles tony
hawk est une fois qu'ils mangent des
semaines tu as quand même en garde à ce
bon sens en train tranquillement je
tourne la 5e ça fait peur comme un as
oui c'est assez impressionnant cavalier
6e décembre les quatre
à cinq pièces elles sont taillées de
plus qu'elles ont du mal à s'exprimer à
cette fois qui est faible tu as une
barrique arrive
si tu vas te faire attaquer ou que
chasse est allé fou qui sont braqués
c'est s'avère très dur aux pratiques
pour les blu ray très intéressant ce
sacrifice
du bas à 3 pour les noirs ici pour les
blancs ici c'est 80 des cas là c'est en
fait un grand coup ouais et sur recul
anticipé je sais pas c'est papon
cavaliers le 4 x 6 et 1.931 c'est en
pratique ces problématiques un break et
grande rio sans plus qu'un peu cagoule
est bon qu'ils gagnent partie mais bon
qui parle dans la forme de sa vie elle
peut y avoir ce sera du mois e4 f4f 3 en
fait à chaque fois avec un gain de temps
sur une pièce derrière le petit roanne
est très faible et le roi qui se fait
ouvrir cette ça fait très peur
et savez vous pas que vous rendez vous
il a reconduit la pièce y allouer c4
et beaucoup surprendre mais
vous êtes très intelligent
qui veut rendre la pièce qui veut
défendre des saints qui considère que le
plan de 5 est trop important pour être
perdu ce serait marrant ce qui est des
princes et 4 mais pensez qu'à des crèmes
à des procès contre j'ai trouvé ça
m'intéresse pas ce serait ce serait
drôle à wigan 5-0
quand même j'aime déroger défaut ouais
t'as le fou c'est ça ressemble un petit
peu à une position destin des cavs a
laissé trois quarts vallée prend 1,4
ouais en fait quand il cavaliere 4 même
si t'en fous cases blanches et ben je
bloque gamme le cocasse voire et au
final et on dessine c'est un plan
crédible le fou de cet hymne jouera
jamais donc je comprends un peu de son
idée c'est pas bête hein une âme parce
que nous on aurait tous mangé leur tous
manger ouais
mais c'est important ce que tu as dit
stock c'est à dire que les noirs ils
n'ont pas le temps de sauver leur
pirogue 4 parce que c'était le cas il
serait très très bien le consolider
heureusement puenzo szilagyi cette fois
pas manger
de bonbons
on n'a pas le temps d'interdire ces
trois que tout est déjà inquiets même si
on en faisait beaucoup de suite et faire
ça à extraire
il serait très bien mais ça va possible
donc c'est pourquoi grande à l'us
capacité à rendre la pièce puis qui sait
qui va derrière
donc récupérer le pion aux points 4 et
installait fameux cavaliers se trouve
vous parle et qui s'est bien passé
et une position du coût
des récentes avec finalement bleus là
c'est brillant au choix de ces paquebots
6 et peut-être retourner contre lui
parce que il n'a pas l'air si bien ici
ben alors là moi j'aime la cavale et g3
pour en fait jouer après le cavalier en
a quatre qui empêcherait tout est un peu
détrempée de toi alors à tomber le jeu
dame gkd à merci si bastareaud mais
l'impression que cameron avait pas grand
chose j'aimerais bien activée toujours à
regarder là où as tout faux ce qui
l'intéresse
ben je vois les cases aussi mais trouvez
que bon en général j'aime bien partager
de darcy
d'ailleurs je passe tu as vu
l'interview de deux personnes dans son
parti contre m'hamed l'erreur il va
utiliser calais gaydamak adam g4 et
terriblement voulait faire tout ce qu'on
avait dit
et elle va beaucoup et 4 dont nous
parlait de
los cabos il me tombe bien le coupon de
4,726 pour casser un pion et mettent une
grosse pression sera sur des six en fait
un qui ne viendrons
admettons prises avec les doigts ici on
n'a pas forcément beaucoup beaucoup et
je pense qu'on a plus ou moins obligé
pour
ne pas laisser les plans bien sûr nous
mène sa structure exceptions pas assez
protégé
donc trees
comment
vous pour empêcher qu'ils bougent le
pion par le fouet du faux parce que
surtout on prend
peut-être pourrait s'activer t'assurer x
6 x 5 à lorient
les deux tournois pour doubler les tours
c'est bien aussi mais bien phu en fait
moi ce que j'aime bien que le fou c'est
que fin comme tours b 2 par exemple qui
à la couette normale et d'ingéniosité
avec tam e3 avec double idée première
dame à trois
sur un petit malentendu et on a aussi
dame g3 qui attaquent des 6 c qui
manquent vous avec le roi donc il ya pas
mal d'idées en suivant ses lacets
probatoire pour les blu effectivement
nous avait pas menti byblos f4v plus que
parent je pense quelle carte et le poids
le coup critique ici à mon avis le
couvert
il devrait jouer dans des lieux cela
donc je vois pas trop ce qui le retient
de rêve il va permettre de prendre à
colombes et je pensais à ce problème de
visa
en plus des fours attention à ces graves
peut tolérer 86 avant 20h fiery
donc à rien à manger d'ailleurs il n'a
pas fait la pub d'ebooks tout ce qu'il
avait à sa cause de ma connexion l'appui
l'a pas entendu certainement
est-ce qu'à d'autres partis qu'on pourra
les voir
certainement
par exemple un parti bleu de braga je
pense la seule qu'on a on n'a pas
regardé ouais je passe c'est pas si
nombreuses il avait tout - ce qui est
ce qui a un coût important pour moi
parce que du coup il fera plus
qu'inquiète il ya peu et du perpétuel il
a essayé ou pas de prendre de noël à
pâques et la zone
ok avec vous tous pour quatre ans je
pense nos camarades et 6 4 donc s'ils
veulent et regarde d'avoir d'autres
perpétuel
ou aval de trois nuls rapide aujourd'hui
randonnée pas avoir le choix de
demander ce qu'est ce qui lie pourquoi
qu'un ciel des meilleurs qu'at-il de
plus que fier haut et en bas de chez moi
c'est très simple c'est une question
d'âge l'expérience firent où il n'y a
que 18 ans donc peut-être que
dans dix ans ce sera le nouveau qu'un
seul
carlson tout ce foutoir
mais il lui permet en fait il faut
savoir que
la plus de la plus glauque
important de dire ça ensuite
ben marche il me bat je sais pas où sont
mes
différents 1 sera fait comme tout le
monde et paca et paroxysme
[Musique]
cependant la question paraît que c'est
pas si facile pour évidemment est
toujours extrêmement doux airs à la base
un an maxime jegat contre lui quand il
était petit il avait déjà des capacités
de calcul hors du port vendres où tu
sais déjà que vous faites ou est revenu
au temps que tu le bas moi jamais évolué
dans la même dimension pluie ça c'est
déjà dîné après bien sûr énorme travail
après moi c'était des clips aussi vous
faire que tu vas prendre plus confiance
aux avoir pris le grinta aussi détesté
par le sentiment que qu'un seul que je
parlais pas par rapport à maxime et au
général en fait des têtes plus la
défaite peut-être que c'est ses
principaux concurrents là vraiment
l'impression que
les spots et là je trouve moi je pense à
elle plus que les autres après c'est pas
forcément l'explication unique même
certaines banques dont je vous ai lu g
unit aux échecs que tout le monde en
fait
pour bernard hinault même mis la main
dessus
ils jouent le plus d'avantagés
et il joue ma fille quoi ils n'hésitent
pas à jouer pendant huit heures en fait
il y
là dans des positions plein de super g
est d'accord pour faire nul alors c'est
peut être ça peu à peu évolué avant tout
cas c'était vraiment ça très bas pendant
de nombreuses années sur toi donc c'est
vraiment révélé lui baïnes jouer jouer
jouer jusqu'à 5 et l'autre c'était
vraiment sa marque de fabrique tu
pouvais faire la différence par rapport
au jeu parle vraiment pas apprécié
allemand de maxime richard aujard mais
de tout le canada de n'importe qui
d'autre en fait c'était le seul à
pousser aussi loin
principal fait donc un tube pour
l'instant mais on espère avoir un match
super du monde le prochain autres maxi
ou votre fille rousse ce serait ça
serait assurément à suivre pour nous
bien sûr
alors qu'à voilà qui vient de fêter la
nuit la continuité pas intéressant là
parce que du coup il y avait dit ok
un
train d'y aller avait l'habitude qui
n'était peut-être chaud pour faire du
late show on peut pas le jeter la pierre
aux revêtements
nascar ouanna il ya 2008 centre a dit il
est entre guillemets car 2612 pour
l'instant que c'est un mauvais résultat
bien sûr
moi cette petite source ou de statut
cour a un peu l'impression que la
libération l'animation de la position de
prévenir que par exemple où c'est le
carton de pousser le sac chez l'un ou
chez l'autre
parce que 4 c 5 mais en fait il ya
quatre ans et 3 et wii de donner un faux
le four
et le toit parce que sur 4 rue pour ces
trois bons auprès de chacun dans son
coin mais
dans un 4-5-1 répondra peut se jouer ses
matches un jour un destin rock
star des blues l'espace
ouais
j'ai même un peu dommage mais c'est ça
aussi je sais ça doit être du d5
le fou est mauvais mais plus
probablement ici encore
sur quatre les pommes j'ai donné aux
tubes et 4
le climat dans lequel pékin aux dépens
du coup là je suis comment
es
tu passé avec vaut mieux en chasse d'un
mach 4 way et nous dit je vais le faire
de force jeunesse est
le 5e jeu fait que j'ai fait cavalier
seul
alors oui c'est là aussi un petit peu
pour les plans
du cougar alaska moche toi
qui montrent son état d'esprit même si
nous mettons doit il aller doit il
pourrait adapter les coûts dire bon ok
non il veut encore se battre ça c'est
bien car c'est un joueur qui je vois
quasiment jamais fait retenu le
rapide toujours pas toujours toujours
c'est assez rare qui mérite ce jour ans
pour voir enfin mieux et même quand il
est noir quand il considère qu'il est
plus fort quoi qu'il a une chance il ya
à jouer donc taillé m100 seconde plus
donc évidemment qu'il a eu peur tu vas
jouer pour gagner
et on bouffe f4 l'été je vois pas
pourquoi on vient juste pour contenir
viendra certes c'est chaud je regarde un
peu
et vendu voilà c'est la panne ou ton
sacrifice de qualité il a joué le plus
discret tour berom et carrières très
intelligent parce que bien sûr égard
c'est idéal de roy mais là bas il ya les
thèmes de tourbe et 4 qui pourrait lui
enlever certains problèmes sur une
planche et 4 way par exemple maintenant
tu vois il faut imaginer madame est bien
autre chose c'est qu'il n'est plus en
prise par ce curieux tout en courbes et
4 à terme et
donc sinon de la f3 ont montré
en fait le pion
secte at repartira il ya quelques
mois lorsque l équipe de france
on s'attend b4 et la savane signé la
pièce et c'est bon sens maintenant on a
un but ont besoin et que tourner car ce
matin je fais toujours un coup pour
revenir et de pièces maintenant on
pourrait tranquillement débuts comme ton
investissent plus sereinement ce qu'on
sait que ma dépendance par exemple
exactement donc et puis il est un peu la
balle c'est encore de keriven c'est à
toi débrouille toi que je te menace
toujours de t'attaquer est imbattable
cib un peu sur facebook et maintenant
qu'est ce que tu as à faire acter pièce
laquelle tu peux plus les améliorée par
rapport aux oscars
parce que tu veux faire du cce que je ne
suis pas sûr parce que ça prendrait la
case même si on fait c'est ça le
problème pour les noirs c'est que
maintenant sur nos coûts comme des sacs
à la case du cavalier indéniable que
prévu sur la prise aussi d'ailleurs les
gardes ont fait pire j'ai peur de
rassembler les pièces voire plusieurs
paires mais
parce que le pion à tous mais de l'autre
la casse des six jours
soit l'autre cavaliers ont baissé et si
ce n'est pas le cas de m mais avec ça ça
on nous parle sur ces cas là vous voyez
est
destiné
[Musique]
au quai souchet marc andrieu y est
c'est quoi la mieux que marc-andré
ajoute qu'on arrête bien que cavalli dès
2004 on en est et la région agression
sur deux jours dams est ingénieux
parce que simon petite reprise en fait
voilà lé ku'damm ses tours 8 et là y'a
eu quoi cavaliers deux ans de lutte pour
la casse le car et on va jouer le 4 mai
notre
dame 100 7 fm
lancé trois épreuves comprend pas aux
souffrances il y avait des relations
comme c'est cette espèce de le monde
66,6
des voix qui sait pas trop où il va
parce qu'il ya un simple repas comme tu
dis il a défoncé
la plus de 30 minutes stouff après a
fait 15 coups leschi
1h15 quoi pour l'un et pour bégayer un
petit peu ce qu'ils font de
ce montant 10 ans alors que barco dryats
lui poursuit son plan de manière très
rapide je me joins pour 4 ouvrira
colonel et après ces pièces ou bien
placé par rapport aux jeunes au poulet
me remercier
après après trois ans voire un peu que l
on peut presque faire tomber 3 mais ça
ne marcherait pas à cause d'eux ça me
rase tout
faire car
c'était mon lit les meilleurs en ce qui
concerne c'est le mauvais le quartier
français car
c'est 3 parce que du lourd maintenant on
a un problème sur le cavalier et pour le
foot arrière plan risque de faire
quelque chose
et par monique à berlin le quart 4
heures d'enfer de la tour la dame dépend
la dame a greater vancouver le cavalier
détroit où j'ai la tête le cou pour
défendre serait de faire un autour d'eux
mais bon
[Musique]
le moment où se trouvent des
pièges
qu'il n'avait pas vu ça
daniel à la longueur ça permet aux plans
de marc gaillard d'aller très très
localisées sur bessan qui n'a plus le
cador voit que la jauge de bien
trop ça me semble est évident que la
plante très bien ici si de 5 avec un ça
va être quasiment pas vu un allez on
accède joseph quatre cavaliers f3 ou à
tout ancien émissaire voilà c'est
extrêmement prometteur pour le petit
français qui affirmerait que voilà après
une certaine morale très difficile il y
avait besoin d'une bonne partie pour se
mettre dedans et
il enchaînerait même si bien que cette
partie je pense qu'il va hassar positif
en termes de même deux points d'eau et
même deux je sais pas d'intrusion ça
dépend même si
leïla -10 donc s'il perd celle là ils
avaient accès à au moins quatre séjours
wii sega ne sais pas ce que je dis c'est
vers la fin entre humains at il argué
moses kigen celle là il serait à moins 4
avec lequel donc il sera en train de
remonter en tout cas s'il gagne deux
parties et remonterait dans
l'emplacement donc c'est bien ça fait
plaisir pour les pouvoirs aura pas
beaucoup de belges avant de la voir et
puis c est en tout cas position
extrêmement prometteuse bon on va
revenir après la pause pour décortiquer
tout ça y est
tout de suite
[Musique]
il
et
m
[Musique]
oh
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ans
oui
[Musique]
on
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mais
alors je suis de retour je raconterai
toujours surtout pour un petit moment
parce que comme vous avez pu voir sa
connexion argent tu étais comme
thématique ali crise est énormément donc
il est facile commander un taxi pourrait
déménager chez un pote
pour une vingtaine de minutes sera de
retrouver depuis là-bas où la connexion
est censé être intermarché voilà
avec les moyens du bord en attendant
c'est un petit peu complexe
mécaniquement avec avec 7.2
d'argentine et de connexions là-bas
pouvoir respecter le temps va mieux d'en
attendant du coup à jouer tous avec vous
pour rendre ces parties du jour
et monsieur ne me font pas vrai voilà
tout ça manque et j'imagine michel ou
quoi on les deux nuls vous a déjà eu
deux jours à tuer
c'est ça c'est complexe bon il allait
rentrer bientôt on aura encore j'espère
que ça ira mieux pour lui
ce qui s'est passé des choses pendant du
coup cette petite pause technique
je me regarde en même temps vite fait
sur les échiquiers là vous avez sûrement
la position de devant une forêt où là on
va partir dans de grandes et on va
partir justement sur sur un vent fort
est ce parce qu'on vous annonce qu'il a
sacrifié la qualité comme on en avait
parlé un petit peu plus tôt
ça va devenir très chaud pour pour grey
donc c'est ça qui a été joué
vous commentez juste avant de partir aux
poses on disait que moi ça me ferait la
casse c'est simple j'ai en tout cas de
dessin par exemple pays reste n'a pas
hésité alors quand vous voyez tour
probable 6
à écouter vous êtes vraiment visuel plus
bon thierry qu'il attention
je pense qu'il avait anticipé quand même
ce goût puisque cette thématique lors
genre de position vous rappelle pour
ceux qui n'auraient que c'est
cet alignement dans la grande anse et
quand même c'est presque tragique au big
blind toutes ces pièces est à trois
contraintes de faire mater et chebat en
train de faire impuissance caste
impuissance 4 pardon colonna pas sûr que
ça lui rapporte beaucoup de points aux
échecs
on va voir
de près ce qu'elle continue et parle
d'art f3
attaqué le plus bref si c'est injuste au
passage je vais laisser leur expliqua
tokyo sécurité de ces sacs c'est aussi
pour contrer pour bekaert ont des vues
juste avant de partir en haut on peut
tomber car c'est une façon indirecte de
défendre son action avec cette double
attaque 6 faisait projet pour libérer la
dame de la défense et donc bonjour
cesari a dit le contrôle agace b4 de ta
tour et donc pas je vais peut-être vous
menaciez c4 si jamais tu t'en avec ta
dam
on forest a l'air très très dérangé
sacrifier la tour et le relève sada
moins manger le pion f6
[Musique]
pas mal
des scalps de la bigne permettre à
orapi de pas mal du tout
donc on attaque le tueur l6
autant dire qu'ici un mot gc 4
c'était certainement
certainement assez suicidaire
admettons aux prises ce qui libérerait
le fou
et donc sur la reprise on pourrait aller
mater avec avec du foie chez cette dame
problème 6 s'inscrire matin tablent sur
casse voire
bien sûr guy à les conventions de ses
dangers
et du coup
tu pousses sur d'amères froid qui rit aa
et saddam un petit peu en défense et
porc ou encore
côté du rond avait au moins elle ne
protège le pion f6
la position moi j'aime beaucoup la
blonde quelle qualité mange pas ce que
vous en pensez n'hésitez pas à nous dire
à part retient du courage en question
revienne question vous impressionnant
cette position donc vous avez une
qualité mois et une planque était
sacrifié bien ce roi noir qui est
extrêmement faible ces pièces qui sont
très loin de pouvoir le défendre
et la plus de démentir des gardons bien
d'être où
le cavalier s'il arrive en faisant par
exemple ou sinon ça peut faire très très
mal
alors on va voir ce que fait mon devoir
rester dans cette position mais
l'entreprise pourrait très bien
s'imposer car cette galerie en même
temps
tout doit être fini a quasiment dès ce
soir là bas thématiquement
en vrai tu me rappelle aussi que tu
n'étais pas là au début
quand celle-ci laguiller sa dernière
partie par forfait dans la rentrée ce
qu'on fait bloc et stp s'il faut aux
convives donc
il a géré admis pour une avance il y
sept points pour nbi jeu le point bonus
de brebis et sera irrattrapable
on n'est pas là alors qu'amélie enfin
byblos pense que c'est une très bonne
idée va devoir amener à ce qu'à l'avenir
la sueur nations ces belles cases pour
viser peut-être le contrôle aussi du g7
la question qu'on peut se poser c'est
peut-être parce que tu en penses à peu
près d'abord le centre pour éviter un
petit peu ouvrir le jeu des noirs
sachant que la dame à rester la
protection elle est obligée là lors des
6es maintenant donc nous cabaye à vingt
onze que c'est plus précis de faire dans
ce sens là
parce que sur l'eau directement
je sais pas exactement pourquoi mais je
sentiment que l'ouverture du gens
peut-être que la même si c'est vrai que
peut être risqué aussi un doublé rare
pouvait en réalité la diagonale du fou
mais je suis peut-être que ça donne un
peu plus de jeu
jours dort à ce qu'on réussira t-elle se
défendre comme ça
on callaway à nu les parties basses du
bois bat andré sera consensus ans je
pense que dans quasiment tous les
tournois le règlement dit que si un jour
nouveau au moins la moitié des rondes
son résultat enfin ces résultats seront
pris en compte et il sera forfait pour
les autres partis c'est comme ça c'est
difficile de trouver une règle
totalement ou juste
la même chose pendant ce temps c'est que
dubois cap agulla bois de répartie dans
ce tournoi
vous
et tout va aussi perdu par forfait
contre viril ou par rapport à la tête du
ps bon ça va peut-être pas tant changé
grand chose
d'heureux de lui être parfait
c'est plus qu'un rapport du coup qui va
être aussi je pose de ou 3e ce soir en
fonction du résultat didier
a bénéficié aujourd'hui donc tu fais en
fait tous bords donc on a l'impression
que les 20 premiers tees battre pour la
victoire de toute façon oui le même le
même sort 20 points à
dubaï pas changer tu peux facilement les
saluts fatto la venue à toi
j'espère que ton arrivée va le faire
apparaître stuff ou qui est partie aux
taxis des ménages puisque aujourd'hui
autant avant-hier ses connexions était
bonne aujourd'hui c'était robben souffre
tout freezer c'est un peu un peu
complexe et pas forcément très agréable
où pourront l'entendre alors créé par
claude option intéressante à dia donc
il devrait voir revenir parmi nous
frêche pour installer chez chez son pote
d'ici je sais par minute peut-être
et donc que vous êtes d'accord avec moi
des cinq ici d'abord qui a l'air très
fort et ensuite ce cavalier la fin donc
très bien joué
tout bateau tentant que sous-entend que
ce tout ferait un jamie peut-être
c'est ça je prends quand on dit trois
fois affrontées trois fois la lampe moi
je
dirais pas sain et pas se veut optimiste
alors ça joue et ça a joué des 5 comme
on s'y attendait
mais c'est même pas que le doute
fatullah sais que j'ai de nombreux
éléments au fil des années
après j'ai envie de te dire des dieux ni
génie
peut-être
sur un an même du coup
s'il vous plaît un petit peu
personnifier la définition du gîte la
corde vous montrer
et qu'elle allait fabriquer
vous jouez comme vous du fond reste
c'est parfait car l iphone qui ouvre le
faut et qui ramène le cavalier
j'ai l'impression qu'on est proche du
bien pour les blancs dans la rue nasser
dans le foot 15 mancini pas mais c'est
pas grave parce que chez les noirs et un
rien du tout qui vaut rien l'opinion ces
quatre reprises mais le pion ces cartes
ne peut pas le confondre c'est comme
tout à l'heure
si on se penche sur une fois ce tour
c'est 80 fois çi ce
schéma tu vas arriver en chais pas
l'ordre de vous le plus précis alors
j'essaie de réfléchir un petit peu à peu
près stable
watch is a l'air prometteur art
peut-être sur fois çi ci est un petit
saut en fait j'attaque le fou et je veux
beunas de
d'intercepter les chèques
qui se lève sans que miraculeux et que
les noirs verse pas tout de suite
se trouver là un très joli pot cesserait
de m lecavalier a
pas des fonds sans trois ce que l'adisq
al ahly arrive en raid5 s'est terminée
ce cas là il vaut vivre d'abord il ya
pas de problème les monstrueux
et donc si on mange on fait qu'un bref
ça rique on attaque la dame sont
beaucoup moins de temps c'est pas grave
d'où selon moi qui nous intéresse et aux
menaces maths
et là va se mettre imparable donc il n'y
a pas du tout des pensions des cases
noires chef chez les noirs
même s'il roule ou a justement besoin
d'amour donc
donc elles sont encore peut-être
maintenant
elle s'est peut-être
n 5 encore
battement d'aile
avec les plombs on a une qualité de mois
et on a un mois plus un jour une
gouttière donc c'est quand même plus
important ici et la dame en crise
jerry seah la pâte gourmand et il a bien
conscience du danger va pas manger ce
pion ses cartes mais je suis sereine je
vais pouvoir gens trouvaient à bord
ont trouvé une des demandes j'imagine si
wagner wall street dont j'ai vite bon
j'ai 6 ans et a priori à rien d'autre
systématique dans cette position quand
on se fait comme un rat kolodjay on veut
être ouverts d'abris agde à 3 dans le
petit coin
[Musique]
peut-être que tu découvriras des
éléments dans le futur sa tour et que tu
vois
et tu pourras de lui attribuer ce terme
on verra bien de le dire à celles ville
propose michel intéressant donc
contraint la case f5
moi je dirais que c'est vie doit
peut-être attendre justement kireka
rallier carrière et de menacer de bondir
sur cette case pour nous jouer
parce que là on laissera peut-être watch
is
et on va perdre un temps anciennement si
on veut bouger notre tour brasparts
mater est déjà en lumière la qualité on
peut la récupération avec les blancs je
suis même pas sûr qu'on ait envie
d'un tour de vis de la battant j'évite
donc je pense qu'on va commencer par
mois chez ça ne paraît pas des cieux
et maintenant surtout comme
lecavalier g3 on fera peut-être
du fou s'est vite
c'est pas évident quand même fait très
peur
moi je suis tu as été joués et cavaliers
trois essais les deux joueurs qui jouent
analystes est
assez impressionnante bagré complexité
de la position après que ça semble assez
pensé
semble assez forcé sur canal 3 et la
grosse invite bienvenue michel
égérie libre ou pas écoute
j'ai une qualité plus je vais je vais
servir je vais essayer de doubler sur la
colonne 'j'ai
foot et de bâtons et ce alors que tu
admires on les noirs
ça veut pas dire qu'ils sont tirés de la
faire
quand même cette prime à long terme la
tour blanche maintenant on va le joindre
à l'action
même des caouecs les blancs bas va
bouger le cul 26 échanger des tables et
la récupérer déjà pas pour la qualité on
va encore le contrôle de toutes les
cases noires leurs actions passées
protéger on aura encore largement à
cette augmentation d'amsterdam même sur
mac parfaite
savard fils ouais c'est sûr en tout cas
je n'aimerais pas toujours peu sûre est
que les noirs ça semble
très effrayant sas après au
[Musique]
hockey on va on va rechange et un petit
peu peut-être d'échiquier pas ce qui
s'est passé plein de choses chez magnus
carlsen
alors d échange massif et le geipan du
monde d'avoir une petite finale
wassila rabat une légère pression
n'était pas ici une gamme à 10,2 pour la
15 e cat et lui avait dit nous tournons
juste interdit
place tout faire reposer beghal besson
qui était intéressant paix car c'est ma
préférée tout est changé ici
l'esprit et dames c4
après quoi visite a dit auquel je le
relève le challenge de tenir cette
finale et choix intéressant riches et
les pauvres prendre la dame
de fer le cavalier de cloud qu'est ce
qui vous semble le mieux et pourquoi
vous avez des idées nation
une fois on va pas chercher à gagner il
sait de manière flamboyante injuste créé
un petit quelque chose pour moi voir une
petite pression
espère craquer
jours à dire sur le long terme
vienne
impressionnant
ouais c'est avec andré cap ça marche
aussi compris
des français car c'est en tout cas
d'abord parce que bon on ouvre la
colonne des plus tôt pour l'heure
où les droits mon secret un pion isolé
faible c'est pas très agréable on les
blancs là ici ce secret est révélé
qu'ils joueraient limite plus tôt pour
deux résultats blancs
bien byblos effectivement on va
apprendre à élever alors prendre du
cavalier ça serait pas catastrophique
ça maintiendrait un statu quo est ici je
pense que
devrait faire une nulle entre autres
chaînes ça paraît très très compliqué de
chercher à créer un avantage dans cette
position pour les blonds et c'est
pourquoi demain car scène comme tu l'as
dit il est réélu mais pour libérer la
colonne mais pour une tour
il ramène d'un pion vers le centre
est ok même si l'abolition d'être
objectivement très proche de l'égalité
au moins il peut espérer un peu joué sur
quelque chose donc
mettre la pression sur bessette et
simplement semblé si on va regarder fois
du ccnb qu'avait le monde edf
voilà on sait pas c'est pas du quart en
scène le royaume comme on a pu avoir
d'ailleurs jusqu'ici dans le tournoi
qu'à gagner vraiment de manera assez
impressionnante la plupart de ces partir
au même pas sur ce coup là il est
repassé en mode quinzaine old school et
je vais je vais une petite finale
tranquille et je vais te mettre la
pression sur le long terme et que je
sais moi le meilleur je vais bien finir
par le faire craquer
alors chers à
part une forest ouais jusqu'aux couleurs
d'abord
avec celle ci ou un coup responsable e
carte de la part de visites un coup très
intéressant c'est une bonne décision son
idée c'est que si on mange
et crible en bas on va se retrouver avec
une structure est très moche le tourne
plus y'a pas faire long feu parce que
nous les tourner par exemple s'est
chargé et va revenir dans la colonne
pour mettre la pression on a
certainement et que je monte un retard
de même que james et kat deviendrait
très faibles
donc sûr que 80 la reprise n'est pas une
option au parti c'est pas rien allez pas
me coûterait trop gourmand pour manger
un curatrice à vous détruire une pâte
pour la structure ou mieux vaut mieux
rester en égalité matérielle et garder
un centre compact ici
avec mathieu bien sûr la sortie de
vidéos mathieu cornette qui réfute
lac-brome
mais bon peu du lot peu de gens
connaissent
même si beaucoup plus la regarder après
il faut se rappeler de curieux
ok et la question je me pose moi c est
ce que c'est ce qui valorise et on
voyait dedans même état d'esprit lui
être quatre derrière
moi m'ont été offertes ce serait
vraiment de les liquider au maximum les
pions
de déstabiliser le 3 tient à la base un
c'est aussi important ça vient des
chaînes de pions il faut souvent
s'attaquer là à la base effectivement
impressionnants particules sur les
ouvertures certainement plus détendu que
la mienne
parce que ce pion aux structures 23
éléphants des d4 et non qu'est ce qui se
passe si on le mange
tout simplement la tour ça va passer les
prochains et noir vous récupérez t4 et
si on récupère le cac derrière il ya ces
deux schémas tombait finalement il y
aurait plein d'essence l'option et plus
les gens disparaissent s'ancrer
davantage ou quoi pour être reproché de
la nullissime
et les noirs là devrait pas avoir de
problème particulier
si on prend le cas directement
il va prendre 3
ea est ce qu'on va essayer de jouer ces
trois si on veut défendre attention ça
pourrait aussi mal porté le bureau que
dangereux
quatre malades est un coup très concret
et très intéressant pour les riders de
jouer vite et je mettrai donc c'est
pourquoi on va réclamer l'égalité
immédiatement et éviter de souffrir sur
le long terme contre 47 de se faire
torturer nos deux heures
curieux de voir comment dans les geôles
va trouver une idée pour jouer parce que
l'endettement
pas quoi puis-je pas très impressionné
par
parce qu'il a obtenu avec les blancs et
je trouve que visiter taiwan façon très
énergique
et vous jamais vendre la peau de l'ours
et car ça nous sommes capables de gagner
n'importe quelle position
et mon sentiment c'est qu'ici
ils y achètent bourse à lui beaucoup de
précis de
24 du lundi 10 mai
on verra il ya aussi la question du
temps il reste une vingtaine de ou un
jouet une petite antenne 2 po et à 25
minutes
[Musique]
sur une paille complexe ok ok on va les
voir marc rodriguez reviendra sur un
sur 23 est ensuite pour voir voici la
bête est joué mais un peu tard
d'évolution que ça va peut-être que chez
maria sa plus bouger en plus il est
proche de l'homme un projet de galions
logement de la ville
la xt l'hyperprésident sa position et
hockey et pas mal de coups de chaud et
peut-être depuis le 4 on était là pour
ceux qui nous rejoignent et mes vues
joueurs majeurs de hésitant qui perd du
temps avec sa d'art
marc baudriller qui avait exécuté le
plan des blancs et s'est passé vraiment
pour l'instant les responsables d'ansar
elle sait exactement comment tu veut
négocier la puissions régler blanc
prendre le centre et envoyer des pions
pour pour attaquer le royal a perdu il
faut
arrêter là et ça sentait très bon
alors dare-dare il va jouer des quatre
dans l'agression qu'il tombe des nues
pour le joueur pêche
légale c'est un peu comme ce que jeunes
nous expliquer sur vidic carrassan on
veut essayer un petit peu de
déstabiliser la structure de pions un
des blancs sa base
au fragilisé donc ce centre mais j'ai
l'impression que les douars sont très en
retard en fait est que la perte de temps
notamment avec la dame va leur coûter
très cher
merci a été jouée
qui sont hyper naturel ce cavalier il y
manque de bonnes cases
j'ai cinq ans où
j'ai ça que ça sent pas bon du tout et
que c'est cool j'ai l'impression qu'on
va peut-être avoir une une miniature là
sont pensés quoi ce gie cinq heures
après jeu de la corde cavalière
et parfois de gazon je pensais qu'ils
allaient venir on achète on va essayer
de
même l'autre justement de défendre
attaquer un petit peu les brèches même
si la ficam m cédric savais pas du tout
au sérieux pour les mains pour r les
noirs donc belmont gilles
b4y à venir avait aussi besoin si on
souhaite la question
ça a juste la rébellion ont fait on l'a
vu lors j'ai l'impression que le bar
candrian peut-être un peu surprendre son
adversaire dans l'ouverture il s'est
retrouvé dans une position n'était pas à
l'aise du tout joueur belge la prime
beaucoup de temps et il n'y a pas
forcément pris le bon chemin alors
martyrs la partie donc tu ce g5
pourquoi moi tu sais pas pour signature
de te tenir pas comme ça faciaux
je suis sûr que tu vises beaucoup mieux
était qu'elle avait que ça
ea et m'a rien appris ce qui me semble
très logique parce qu'on passe il avait
reculé sont fous aux îles il aurait
toujours été mieux je sais par admettons
f2
ab les noirs ne pouvait pas faire
cavaliers
et leurs leur vole leur rock d'exploser
parfaite ici après la prise au rêve si
ce n'est pas sa voile en éclats quoi
lasser ses opérations gruyère chez les
noirs
ces opérations gruyère et marc-andré la
hache des points ici et il est affûté
leur salle et ses rappels dans les
premières rondes de tournoi ça se
passait pas bien il achètent pas ses
mots et raté des tactiques étaient même
parfois facile surtout produire à son
niveau et on sent qu'il a pris confiance
que il envoyait car adieu 411 était
magnifique
car c'est bien de faire très très mal il
a eu l'idée de le libérer l'intégrale de
cette dame pour aller manger à chis et
faire un gros bisou devant lui le roi
noir
le plaisir de le voir jouer à ce niveau
de cours cela tient du lhc cours
c'est vraiment plus ma ville est
métamorphosée depuis à peu près le
premier jour de repos il avait une belle
mais elle ne compte pas contre mon
incident ensuite il a il a enchaîné avec
un très beau matt ou tram
entrevoit warmerdam et avant-hier il a
fait encore une belle vue là non il faut
voir comme stella nulle part dont il a
fallu la clé noir et
aujourd'hui on va partir pour gagner
j'ai eu prise du cavalier
et d'ici là pas projet raciste si ces
barreaux paix si les embauches il sort
il a repris avec 4 alors
ce que les deux heures est fort il a
fait entrer en gare pour libérer sa tour
et puis s'en va nulle part
salué dans
la collection de stuff aujourd'hui été
catastrophique
d'ailleurs j'espère pour toi que demain
ils stream world depuis son jeu sont pas
tirés partir en taxi il y aura du vélo
on retient c'est en effet les pieds
et le temps qui live dans le petit des
ménages devrait
retrouver stouff avec on l'espère une
voie plus fluide et il m'a dit la
prévenue que pourront-ils mangent leur a
notamment sur la dernière ronde débutera
à midi heure française mais chez nous on
a retenu sera vite heures du matin ils
n'étaient pas motivés pour aller chez
son pote
mais
c'est ça c'est à nous peuple je pense à
mon avis
c'est pas sûr de le revoir
et rock ce
forfait de dubaï et a
du coup cette victoire 2-5 alors est-ce
qu'une victoire par forfait d'un an
c'est automatique
ça pourrait être ça suffit at once il
était payé un pronostic mais ça se
passerait pas bien ah ben quand on parle
du stock
est revenu le voilà ce que vous
l'entendez de
wels va je pense que normalement oui
parce que je suis et numérique c'est
normal maintenant passes ton temps bien
parfait au québec est vite y avoir voir
prague la coller un kaoua nadjaf alors
j'ai pas du tout les positions la nuit
tout à l'heure à l'école aux hommes pour
vous attendez vous à tous j'ai cédé
récupère ma caméra
et mais l'avait perdue stouff l'aï
perdue stuff
alors est ce qu'on va me retrouver sur
le live oui il y avait pourtant raté
jardon
bon ce contournement jeu moi je plante
en
regard de la position de marc andré ya
hélas il est proche de gagner mais je
sais pas c'est quoi la
s'est passé a fait des bonnes choses
mais je viens de les expliquer déjà tu
peux reprendre à partir de ce moment-là
de la cavale de villate - degrés nous
verrons ont libéré saddam et
il a repris et maintenant il a battu l
expliquer tout ça ok
il ya une pièce de moi m'ont menace d'un
point à 6
d'un probable si ce qui ferait
maintenant 17 qui forcerait car l
épreuve 6 1 pour on rend la pièce pour
les peaux mates et du coup je pense
qu'une développe blanc peut aussi de jeu
e5 défendre f6 effet après je vais faire
après dun prend d'emprunt à dix avec un
matin angers7
je me sens responsable
bref si sa missive façon la position et
déjà
et déjà suicidaire s'est terminé ses
kamikazes il ya pu y a plus de solution
pour le roi noir qu'est trop
passionnelles cavaliers c'est ce qui va
tomber de bouc
ouais et donc le fin du tour six
que ça comme je vous ai fait bien
journaux quand le fou et on vient à
dépendre la tour le but c'est d'en créer
un nouveau pion m6
donc du coup là je vois c'est quoi v3b 3
à 3 716 vraiment désespérer
les priorités
c'est l'afrique est ce qui est donc en
fait c'est regarder matériel les blancs
on tourne plus 67 position extérieure si
on devrait s'attendre à avoir une pièce
deux mois vous serez sûrement gagnant
pour prendre comprend un rouage cette
fougue et ça va vraiment dans un monde
direct je pense parce que son procès
devait y avoir droit j'ai eu dans ma
poche c'est sa
défense
perdu ses soutiens je vois pas caméra je
sais c'est normal on va donc plus bas
remedy courtier revenu ça c'est buggé
donc j'arrive je vais leur mettre bas
dans la poudreuse tu prouves
on va faire des petits réglages
[Musique]
tu vas voir coin du propos nostang
balle hors jeu pas fait du tout le tour
des partis donc je me souviens équipe
seconde la manager des vannes forest
parce que c'était juste et sympa
ok
ok alors donc se passer plein de choses
donc finalement il a réussi un jeu ds 5
donc tout à l'heure on avait dit que le
coût de 5 ce qui a un coût qui pourrait
être difficile à jouer dans une position
si le renoir ainsi qu'aval et n'en
arrive est allé en 8e rang 8 10 6 pour
attaquer ses 4 mais là maintenant je me
rende compte que je n'arrivais un
langage était pas pendant 20 minutes que
vonn forrest a lâché 3 6
et ça l'a en fait assez prometteur j'ai
envie de dire flash 4 qui va arriver
attaque et f6 la tour qui va venir aussi
en f1 pour attaquer encore une fois
hexis et sa valeur très très fort pour
blanc moi j'aime beaucoup de blancs et
si ces récepteurs
et ses shows et mais voyez tout reprend
ici tout à l'heure on en a parlé
rapidement sa santé en fait parce que
toutes les caisses noires étaient ll
dame occulter la défense et du coup
annoncé en réussisse sa part et c'est
hyper logique est en fait y'a plus
personne en défense donc tu va balancer
une logique donc j'aime beaucoup la
position dans forrest malheureusement
bon c'est
kevin qui a parié dessus
c'est le seul problème de l'analyse
qu'avec dire que messi non
sinon un j'aime beaucoup beaucoup de
blancs et si oui le que lecavalier à 5
il est hors jeu pour revenir en jeu il
faut revenir en bessette et en d6 parce
qu'en début de servir à rien n'aurait
pas de carrière et cavani blessé des six
ça peut être très très bien
mais du coup pour ça il faut vous la
dame dont convient qu'il perd pas mal de
temps et en plus le fou doit rester là
ans et 8 pour empêcher les cavaliers 5
dans la si nous faisions qu'un pjak est
très intéressante pour les pour les
blancs je vois même pas en pratique
c'est sain c'est la famille alors on
peut imaginer des trains cavaliers 17
ici peut-être et sur x 4 tours g6 et le
retour f1 comment je défends à 17
la crèche 4 progrès 6 1 pour ff13 g7
est là comment je continue parce que
c'est pas si simple de trouver vraiment
défense a ramené le fourrage 5-fu de
mécènes sépare du temps que je vous dois
d'alerter ses trois
cavaliers f5 peut être intéressant des
fois et puis on prend chasser ou à
pionsat sa ferme la colonne donc ça
m'arrange pas mais de sa vague la tour
donc le 17 pour
casas les trois
du tout
d'en prendre logique mais kovalev 5
c'est dommage le faux site n'a pas bougé
un cil
c'est un bon temps doux
d'ambouli 3me cet équivalent et décide
d'enlever un
jusqu'à validé 6 en france pour ça que
vous ramenez
serait si
bas prix prend 1,4 donc ça moche des
pions
sinon
à j'ai une idée ok damage sac ce qu'il
veut faire la marche 5 et sur quels
points décisifs à 3.6 le génie
non
jean cavailles des six
mois je pense que fatwa
résultat 10 6 1
3 souvent entendu que les contours d'un
sens moi je la perte de rapporter ce
propos au cas où
c'est pratiquement il s'est passé quoi
au juste le terrain de génie a été
attaqué lui me semble c'est vrai parent
qui en sont ou non
c'est vraiment libre et 7,4
elle a dû se tromper de mots je pense l
arrivée elle arrive qu'un mauvais rêve
de match
il ya plus des penseurs ya trois quatre
ans à 4 attaquants y a personne qui peut
venir mais mais rien puisqu'on l'idée
j'avais mon idée très intéressante à
arida match 5 quand même ce que me dit
place tactique en vrai qu'à valider 6
par exemple elle a parfois réussi ce
village est d'amener 5
pas d'accord mais
non j'ai raté quelque chose peut-être
parce que sur ton les six du monde adam
et suroît bouge bien je mange la dame et
après je mangerai aussi toutes les
options mais le problème des
technologies le curieux 4 buts et 6 et
georges 2,5 et je n'étais pas assez en
france
moi je sens que le byblos qui va se
prendre il va 120 ban il continue à
parler mal de protéger et nous les fait
se profile et non cela n'a pas droit de
dire ça
car j'ai refusé de répéter aux haïtiens
ici la bouger sa tour les joueurs qui
venaient de zigzaguer un petit peu car
asie dont je vous ai je tort celui du
coup a écopé de cinq cas pas voulu 4
vous avez regardé qu'avait
l'intéressement ouais je pense que là le
foot bien ils leur ont gardé un prise
prise qu'à valider cette dame ces deux
menaces matt discretos
discrétos inscrire tous
j'ai fait nous parrainons bbc mon
abstenir
milieu d'eux j'aime bien ce qui fait les
petits prix le gadget roi heenok est un
très beau chiffre de 7 6% ouais mais dès
qu'il y aura un jour une autre appli f
ok on va voir mais on va écrire d'un
call
sakho kovalev lui tient tout comme toi
que la dame ciadoux es mais en vous avez
que la tour c 8 et le fou bien il joue
pas et le cavaliere fuite et ben ça
tient tout ça donc j'ai peur que ça soit
un peu posera pas ses amis de noël
que doublé on peut créer des dames
d'attac mais
au final
je suis d'accord
et c5
ils doivent s'en fout camaïeu de est
peut-être la frousse et 6 à 4 peut être
aussi une possibilité a perdu son
attaque c'est de l'eau ce qui valide son
tour
ouah marc pado
ouais alors peut-être on peut voir des
cavaliers g34 et ses attributions des
six ouais
bonne chose d'ailleurs de manger cinq ou
six équipes arrivées genre genre
cavaliers trois peut-être dame de cinq
chiens
ouais je pense qu'un vrai très bien ici
mais il prévient venue d'un club après
combien j'ai l'impression contre les
gros noms jean raquin 140 nordiques
c'est ce que logiquement ça va pas tout
à fait pareil ce n'est pas tout à fait
relâcher et à jouer
bon elle est très bien mais bon il va
blender
sera pas là non pas le tournoi non je
vous rappelle ici les gars on soutient
tout soit tout indien prague la source
de tous ces ennuis et aurait eu des
vides stouff pied bat voix la liste et
d'ordinateurs j'ai tout de suite aux
interrogations jeunes qui me dit mistake
on a vu la jauge accès fashion
évidemment mais ça c'est de la merde
ça commençait pas moi j'avais des maux
je sais pas c'est que du coup grâce à
tour des huit pas un coup de tournevis
et baldé qufu si c'était plus possible
on se lie au restaurant des finances et
si ce n'est que quand tu es
pour rien s'est il dit que c'est mistake
parce qu'il avait un cookie qui était
probablement meilleures
dames l'ong avait l'air sympa aussi un
ont fait discret un suivi de joueurs
dame j'ai cinq ans menace ma danger de
quand même et c'est pas si évident que
paraît le mot de passe de cavaliers f4
cavalli les camions mais il tient à
thouars avec bien sûr sur un fil quoi et
cavaliers j'ai trois pages que je lâche
5 es
bon en tête j'ai du fou au 4 mai c'est
pas si simple j'ai l'impression
donc avoir
pas intérieur
dont david pouvait rebondir
jeu tout faux à faire une petite pause à
ça faisait longtemps oui surtout pour
toi du coup on se retrouve un point fut
lourd ensuite
avec ce je vous laisse faire la victoire
certainement à venir si ce n'est pas
déjà le cas de marc andrieu mauvais dit
dans mon cerveau vous se demande
du coup parce c'est une nouvelle
victoire en 26 coups avec les plombs et
banif turinois du la française et c'est
hyper bien et du coup on verra demain du
coup marc andré a donc avec quatre
points maintenant sur 11
qui aura les noirs demain du coup
contre l'allemand roven google est
encore à sa portée
ouais donc il encore un jeu reprend et
là il a un joueur qui pour le coup mon
fort que lui sur le papier il y aura les
voir l'en croire ce qui se passe et
engalin parti je vous rappelle qu'il
aura les blancs contre contre higazi
comme celui qui massacrent tournoi avec
qui à 8000 survenu jacques laisné
aujourd'hui avec les noirs très vite il
a fait nul contre la villa de l'e3 mais
justement ça le jour
oui d'accord j'avais un bug est réparé
et me disais donc du coup de neuf sur
douze noms 9 sur 11 pardon c'est moi je
crie la survie jusqu'à garde du corps
devra trancher
stuff
aller tout de suite à la diète
[Musique]
à
vous
[Musique]
oh
à
ça
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oh
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et
[Musique]
et nous sommes de retour avec le saumon
images
ce qu'il faut être plus encore on
assiste et peut-être
peut-être à la vie quoi je suis maudit
chic et devant de presse sur gueye 20
pouces à l'air de
wever de plus en plus du résultat s'est
passé quoi exactement en fait dans cette
partie là de mon absence de
pouvoir attraper ce show
you était là et puis avoir ce fameux
tour b1 pour jouer b4 propre c'est jerry
a le look ou d'ailleurs visage et ses
sacs et là où le reste il a envoyé tout
autre problème 6 sur la cité
et reines un
conte à budapest ont attaqué le pion sur
l'avion sont bien quelques minutes dams
et 6 pour défendre la ferme avec des
sauts mais qu'après il abandonne rex
pour viser les cases ok mais que des
coups très logique est très bon a priori
de la partie des plans
moi je suis ton reste caché
aux arrivées là comme ça et la manoeuvre
avec ce qu'il faut
taper un peu ce qu'on avait dit tout âge
km2 dont il dépend en liberté 9 mois
plus tard
vous 17 je me laissais sur notre tour
venir à la rescousse alors de la musique
bref un
rappel la dernière place ont dû eux ont
des formes ont
droit les 7,5 ou qu'on n'aime pas du
tout l'ordinateur là je sais fâchent
ouais
d'habitants si vous voulez faire quoi
ici tout reproche
c'est compliqué
soit mal faire 5
perdons en fait
l'âge ans tu laisses un peu
mangé après faire rager cette thématique
avalant des six c'est dire que bon
hockey est un jeu de mots et
j'ai des compensations parce que le coût
des trois gammes très mauvais ouais
d'accord
c'est très possible que j'ai mangé un
nom mais en pratique c'est compliqué à
prendre sa décision parce que ton rang
et where dupéré pts 6
c'est assez chaud ouais ok
airways et c'est pour défendre
les deux
ramener la dernière pièce au garage roy
s'est logiquement fait ce qu'il veut
faire je pense là c'est peut-être fou g4
aurait changé le foot 15 blanche et
après traces alléchant la rentrée pour
le cavalier cas des cinq citoyens
riverains 5x peut pas être capturé c'est
terminé voilà donc du coup faut deux
pour jouer bruce congé quatre rouges et
quatre ans c'est sa seconde du coup à
ste croix
ménages 3 câblos magique et c'est
bizarre en fait je crois bien cette bête
à fourrure jca-t juste se tient face à
gagner la partie si j'ai sur des fous de
cases blanches est finie sécurisé cet
avant poste alors certes ça permet tout
prendre je crois en moi qu'à part de
marché donc au vu de la jauge
il n'y a pas de couilles c'est quoi de
bouffioulx voilà je pense qu'il est fou
tu ne dis rien complètement avec voir
jouer sans eau fait ainsi ré pas plus
compliqué que ça
et donc la ligue 1 est ce qu est ce que
je vois si là il a fait ce qu'il fallait
fois seul où elle après bien ouais parce
que si on veut de la qualité à pour
abroger m6 derrière
ceux auxquels vous faire partie
ah oui service à bouger voilà ça leur
fille ni un bref si ce qu'il a récupéré
le matériel
ici et maintenant c'est le patron des
cases noires
après il peut même y avoir des trous
pour prouver sa calculé l'un c'est vrai
oui c'est vrai dit mme parent j'aime pas
mais calcul est bon
c'est d'ailleurs aussi ça wen en fait
non par principe de lumbres 15 mars
avril il avait l'air très très fort
c'est pour ça que juste sans calculer un
ouais tu avais simplement victime en
salaire finir d'un procès tenu à
être le plus facile mais jouent
toutes leurs biens le maroc
one forest belle partie en rangs très
serrés yade aux tournois qui a été
capable de fulgurances exceptionnelle de
coutras quinzaine où il a fait du lac
noir c'est une teinte spécifique il a
gagné un certain nombre d'autres aussi
avec style et adverse il a aussi parfois
un petit peu
merdouille et pour garder le parti qui
était évitée alors je me rappelle
d'avoir des bureaux il a perdu ses
contres doudou rapport final de
cavaliers
mais quand même pas grand chose à
craindre
se reprendre de ces pages ne pas devenir
partie des trois candidats
a donc peut-être un peu
voilà il a fendu il te rapport
à l'or noir parce qu'il a fait il l'a
fait en fait que une trop trois nuls
partie des bâtiments des lieux où ce
père du rapport batch promenade a perdu
mamediarov perdu car akin battu ville
dit qu il va battre bhiri il restera à
jouer
noir duda et blanches encore ok
s'il y arrive et non à la loi s'il gagne
il l'aura 5e sur 12 donc stop algérie et
du coup on se retrouve avec un rased
leur cinquième chrono c'est pas la
moyenne
imbéciles raciste laquelle
il a convié à prendre il à 4h30 nayda
comme elle a quatre et demi mais c'est
ça sera 5 admis sur le site official
who couleurs à la moyenne avant
voilà salue la foule salue un peloton
arrive au moment de la démonstration
mathématique et le théorème de stouff
qu'il a conseillée dans toutes les
écoles mais 4,4 et munitions disent que
5e en 12 jeux bastille comme ça
bon encore faut-il conclure
moi il a 24 minutes dans cette position
avant le fort est
donc c'est sûr vous progresserez qu'il
va le voir il a déjà vu d'ailleurs mais
il doit réfléchir s'il a pas mieux je
sais pas ou plus lents comme dame g3
même un quart élèves cinq ans regarde un
peu effrayé
willam g3 leur bien
être qui est à 690 unités
village
ayant juste en fait c'était un piège
mais là vous voyez ainsi si vous
regardez là la comparaison entre le fou
et six cavaliers à 5 complètement un
coup tu manges
du cavalier l'hommage à la nouvelle avec
lecavalier au bord la
lra justice maximy fait mieux avec ses
tuyaux plonge vers la barre celui de
jerry par contre
il n'a pas bougé ce profil a joué à
d'autres coups bas dans le même esprit
mais peut-être plus facile damas cat
qu'elle en est un excellent rupo
puisqu'on est dommage c'est donc où il
falloir qu'il fasse la mer comme lima
défendra alors son camp mais futin comme
défense au pire des cas les dames elles
chutent ça aux pirates dans prend il
faut prendre 5 est ce que tous réfutent
maintenant et on rêve 7,5 ou pour éviter
les redites landreau genre d'hommage
history of 7
mais
auparavant
c'est le drama tâche de nice pau on veut
pas lui donner
à fossettes
fouet cette fondation de
ouais je mange d'une pièce a pris adam
f6 ça évident et amati
[Musique]
maintenant les fuites
il ya eu 5 qui va tomber j'ai eu cinq
enfants je déçu ce guerrier 5 qui arrive
aussi là encore l'idée de fatou ici
d'éclat tabou shalit et 6 ans rappelle
peut-être directs
n'ont pas de ses pattes oublier ma
partie d'un fan pour ce qui est des 5 et
6 ça va être mat
ouais c'est la boucherie s'il vous vient
d'un radar sait très bien ce qu'il a
fait c'est encore mieux que fawcett que
vous resterez que je veux dire qu'ils
étaient qui était certaine bonne façon
de gagner aussi mais
mériterait si le jeu ouais donc du coup
de coeur que c'est plus sain
plus brillant que je propose de quoi
sont pas ils te laissent paraître pierre
d'un mascate est vissé sur case noire at
et c'est le cauchemar pour aniche
aujourd'hui
la retour un petit peu sortir il a
quatre parties de suite avec pas mal de
réussite et un gain parfait
donc ce qu'elle a montré sur un an il
méritait pas forcément d'être
aussi proche de la tête j'ai envie de
dire il avoue souhaiter bonne chose mais
bon c'était pas
fan de skate partie de suite gagné
ça me paraissait bien telle vue des
différentes parties
assez bien réagi d'accord je suis à fait
d'accord il a eu de quelques petits
cadeaux
notamment vont le trouver 6 2 caruana
elle a eu le forfait il me faut refaire
prénom il ya il va bénéficier aussi à
d'autres joueurs arrivent et méchant
klaus et pour envoyer en l'air bizarre
bon
et alors wave asie alors noah bin c'est
un mec là qui nous demandent pourquoi
dans la nuque la ville d'angers 4 ben
tout simplement parce que cavaler j'ai 4
milliards engrangés 4g dans le futur on
veut pas échangé pour l'instant sky est
un peu foi me fous et pas une bonne
pièce
notre cavalier tant qu'à faire dame
nature a claqué la chimie ou le sac web
6 mai ou d'apport aux visites de
s'échanger par contre ce qui est hyper
fort un système qui est très important
donc de sacrifier le pion des
renforcements d'avoir bougé pour un
style quel meilleur des cinq ou qu'on a
un peu la même idée je pense que toi
d'aller activé notre cavalier sauf que
là il passera dans une case où il peut
pas se faire échanger par loulou est mal
pourquoi c'est donc plus efficace comme
ça
beaucoup plus tard
est-ce qu'on n'ira pas dans la partie
depuis prague pendant ce temps là
partent ou alors ma mais en fait je vois
que les groupes en fonction prétendre à
mieux répartir partout acuité été joués
berry-au-bac sportfive
ordinateur il donne un avantage écrasant
pour les noirs allé et j'ai un peu du
mal à voir pourquoi
faire une pièce alors
on aurait été la soupe pour davy tué par
karan a donc fait le gibbon vient
contester la colonne des
revenus de l'est comme un guerrier bouge
on sait jamais hein ben oui
une caruana moi je pose c'est très
logique se fume du thé chaud
et du coup la finale va avec confions
bravo rapport à ce point e
elle sera juste est très prometteuse
pour les doigts en fait ben ouais parce
qu'un peu passé quoi
donc on en prend cavale et c3 et
apparemment ça roule c'est un volant
d'heures la part de prague parce qu'il
est fou qu'ont ces trois
gendarmes français troisième acte du
couloir boyer
et surtout prend à la place
du groupe 4 est assez joli au très joli
et les milliers de fermes at du couloir
voilà mais du coup sûr un coup comme
dame c'est un pur empressé le maître du
couloir et garder les
commandes la ddt ou juste
parce que
peut-être que je peux le jouer comme fou
prend bien épouser +14 ne pas dire en
fait c'est juste que
oui en fait tu vas pas réussir à
dépendre des pions quoi d'avoir juste la
pierre regarde ton faut en fait un
cahier pour instaurer pactiv mais il va
revenir au jeu alors que ce fou c'est
condamne est un petit peu un bout de
bois j'ai envie de dire jusqu'à la fin
de la partie et espions à quatre formes
ses passions tout de suite
car en plus tu m'aimes pas défendre
parce qu'il ya un mois du couloir
pour avoir une quinzaine d'années ou à
d'autres battues fin je crois au g3 est
en fait je rappe loin encore
et à toi de jouer la dame va venir rosso
et lecavalier au pouvoir s'est activée
par exemple comme ça bon chemin
et du bois va jouer avec un pion de plus
quasiment le pion à qui est ultra
dangereux et un cavalier qui va alterne
dominer ce faux donc stratégiquement
c'est pas une tactique qui gagne une
pièce cegedim taille type simplifie et
donc la tactique ici se met au service
de la stratégie pour transposer la fin
de partie facile avec le bouquin alliés
contre le mauvais faux et la force du
pion par
roxane tactique qui va permettre au noir
d'avoir une position
traditionnelle mandat écrasant quoi
ouais
tu peux pleurer puisque à la caméra
j'aime bien de voir où était jouée par
fabi et doute pas que je le ferai 4 va
suivre oui ils ceux ci dessous vous faut
il le berrocal
si tu manges en c3 avec le fou c'est à
lui que c'est la partie et là je faut 4
caruana qu'il retrouve
turcot ben bassou son niveau en plein là
quand il joue comme aujourd'hui c'est le
cas le roi d'un numéro deux mondiale
impitoyable
c'est la régularité qui lui fait défaut
ces derniers temps et à twitter pour la
séquence est à quatre tous convient
d'analyser
est-ce qu'on est fort quand même voilà
ça se compte en quarts maladie dont
on espère quand même quand il est mort
deux mondial c'est moi
c'est plus facile chez quant à une loge
qui te dis attention
attention
le canadien pourrait jouer si on joue
aux échecs tu as mais sans avant lundi
jusque là jours avant une clause ça
pourrait être marrant parce que vous h
place à la baule avait le niveau des
joueurs à sa belle ville et enfin ça
réduit pas les apprend les gardes sont
arrivées elles sont là en tout cas il y
aurait beaucoup moins de gain manqué je
pense à tous ces camps chercher c'est
quand il ya un gars donc tout de suite
là tu demandes alerte et c'est comme les
problèmes semblent dire
les joueurs qui s'étaient entraînés la
difficulté c'est mon parti c'est de
savoir
surtout que ta personne quitter al assad
selon l'organisme
et oui à fleurs alors le fou est pas
tout le temps mais y en quelques uns
vallier bien sûr dans les positions
fermes et le cavalier de haut bild une
position debout vers c'est plutôt le fou
est ce qui compte aussi c'est la couleur
des pions de la structure est là le site
était le gêne parce qu'ils ont un socle
à devraient être inspectés blanc ne
s'est encore pas bien mais
alors ça me j'ai un truc à dire a alors
tout à l'heure en off
je t'ai dit que car ça n'allait pas j'ai
longtemps et 8 finir parce que pour moi
c'est elle est nulle facile eh bien on
va gagner très vite en fait car c'est de
la gagner très vite et il va gagner là
bas
vous invite à aller voir qu'est ce qui
s'est passé elle y dit à craquer
théâtre à pied il ya pas tous qui veut
une pétition pour la jauge au partage
c'est pas bien on pourrait en tout cas
le proposer à la fidh organisa des
vannetais juste une fois comme certains
scream
awards et un tournoi avec la joue
justement en vous marc
jonget
moi je
me
réjouis pas
qu'est ce qui s'est passé profite parce
que ouais là tu étais parti à ce moment
là d'être un taxi vie dites moi
j'analyse et ça explique jeff carr du
parti bien là bien avant en fait un bref
mais du coup j'étais très content au des
coûts de vie dit très content on lui
dira personnellement ça me voilà mais il
avait joué les bons coups pour forcer
les significations par leucate et f4
vous qu'on avait réalisé le sans
déstabiliser à la chaîne la structure en
option mais ça avait l'air de mener à
des
pas des simplifications
adultes stouff way
et malgré tout ça a mal tourné alors
qu'est ce qui s'est passé c'est là
peut-être le temps qu'il est un petit
peu fait craquer bas comme dans vos deux
parties c'est chez lui le temps c'est un
problème dans la deûle c'est que cette
position alors certes c'est avec la
bombe emea beau structure et blanc tu
devrais pas être perdant dans cette cool
ici à priori avec les draps
de réseau mobile 6 et 5
logique c'est ça aussi
alors est-ce qu ici est-ce que c'est par
là qu'il a commencé à déconner ryan
o'neal plan là il a donné le pion vous
les faire découvrir
appris l'agencé 5 pour essayer de toi en
plus d'autres tu peux me dire ouais bon
c'est moche mais on a même structure ce
que j'aurais fait enfin ça me semble
logique et cavaliers des 6 e 6 e pardon
mais plus qu'un jeu des formes et des
trucs et puis
je pense qu'il faudra il faut voir ces
cinq ans c'est ça il a plongé tout bien
fait ça en tête on avait des idées
quelques heures ont fait la vie dure à
dia est prise
ces quatre haddaoui peut pas bouger
effectivement mais c'est des fois on
dirait que non c'est pas con ce qu'il a
fait non plus en fait
ils dépensaient sans qu'ils aient des
barbes et ceci avec la convertit au
caire ces cartes tricolores qui prend la
4 cavaliers 3km nafta vraiment 3 3 aux
siens il est simple tout de suite tu
fier d'eux y a pas de force dans ses
trois tours vite à l'aïs la rue trop
fort cette année en fait là parce qu'il
a trop voulu forcer les choses et au
final et ben il va il va par des
plantes mais renvoie sur la roue a eu
deux matches qu'on crée un staff et mes
deux blessés
et là ils menacent pas une menace c'est
la partie mais c'est pas bon puisque le
pion est trop fort
son idée c'était de faire un truc comme
ça
j'imagine pour bouffer pour surveiller
cette fois
et du coup car c'est bye résume-t-il au
final l'activité des rois c'est zéro et
on regarde bien le regard de ce
voyage de sa force est de forcer la
nulle pa tu as raison ce trophée
et l'ayatolah je pense exactement
celle du bien indivis décidemment jean
pions
et pour voir arriver à temps et c'est
nul en fait la durée de vie si tu pensé
c'est sûr elle a raté cette idée des six
taureaux et 47 ça c'est le genre d'idée
on sait bien qu'il faut pas le rater de
pizzi éviter ne laisse pas passer
croyait tous vont devoir s est très bien
joué
on la tarde toujours à 10 à
un jour atteindra donc le gamin cède par
ce retour à 5 aux menaces et tours de 5
walf la 3 6 4 ou froide et cap plutôt en
d4 1 but ne devrait avoir que pour 5
pour ses 8 on sait jamais et donc là si
on essaie de passer d'un vrai raconte
mme roy
et bah je pense que tu
[Musique]
c'est la partie stocker ou à rester avec
les deux jours
c'est la torah 2 je me demande si il
faut pas de tours d2 6 mai
dans les 8 3 et 5 malraux 17
il faut surtout rade il faut jouer qu'il
faut jouer un
double jeu hein sinon les jauges tiny
jeu l'ordinateur
torah de jouer vous prenez on va
s'attarder sinclair n'a pas le choix oui
rien
parce que le roi de la dans le carré
ouais
donc trois des cinq jours at elle pour
cassano plus qu'annoncé dans les
positions comme ça il est hyper sûr de
lui failli sur quoi les bonnes odeurs de
vérifier si cette inversion qui sait
non mais en plus
l'éditer mal au tendon qu'il veut matin
pression
on pas qu'il puisse réfléchir trop
longtemps
donc un peu comme l'a fait hier
nous battre qui a craqué qui a rappelé
qu'un valet achoui enfin dans la partie
contre grandiose et je vais trop vite
trop
donc échec où il fonda était juste notre
prédiction était normal droit s'est
situé parc 1,7 à la caméra walton
pauvres et maintenant il a lancé mme
turbé nintendo
ouais donc la b5 donc tu as tort comme
qu'il arrive à attraper les
empêcher d pendant six ans
est-ce que c est ce que c'est vraiment
gaillon se trouvent déjà
c'est une gueule de gaillon l'impression
vers l'est alors imaginons 17 des cadres
tours 8 d'ici peu
les 4,8 et à cinq reprises c'est un
christian même temps en fait à chaque
couleur de l'argent elle tourne est-ce
que je peux me battre
car cela en fait ici
le tour de force à mettre ton roi de
votre wii u 17 et pas forcément le
meilleur coup je pense pas
parce que le roi il doit revenir à moins
de 3 6 7 6 6 3 dz je pensais même pas
puisque à
chasser le roi l'éloigner du pied au
maximum et jamais aussi tour cet échec
et huras est oui passer derrière busch
plus mon pote et après on
a l'option b peut boucler mais ouais
mais je mens rea coiffant glace je
mangeais plus intéressant dans un final
très intéressante est ce que c'est bien
une langue parce que
c'est ce que les noirs peuvent s'en
sortir dit il
l'instinct dit xia lian mais notre
instinct n'est pas infaillible
j'ai triché je triche est un challenge
annonces ou celle du coup tours 7 ok ça
manque encore une fois je suis un génie
leur tour cette question apple a4 une
première fois c'était le 17 qui perd
tout avantage
à retour c3f si cela est dit ou vos 4 ou
pharmacie
ça par contre c'est trop dur qu'on voit
ça
passe mal en attente d'une +4
il joue le coup les bains est dit que
c'est nul
typique ne cède pas là il redonne 1
mentalement vous savez aussi des seniors
par bête ce genre de position ou des
fois où la tourner a sacrifié sur le
pion est un fonds qui va arriver et du
coordinateur de loin c'est à peine une
grosse machine va dire de la merde et va
changer à chaque
fois c'est comprendre revenus du groupe
j'essaie de comprendre déjà
1.479 passé à sécheron pour empêcher de
bouger de là à faire un stick
je comprends rien j'ai mis la ronde il
comprend rien
il dit en fait c'est obligé thorsten
walles et six tours 4 oublier voix et
jean les zones et selon les sept
dernières séances mourra tu vas tu es tu
allé auparavant arrive trop vite
on va jouer pour voir admettons qu'on
armait mois 17
b 4 jours j'imagine
b4 ok chèque à temps
car ça nos jouets mais il a pas de
ceinture il a joué je fait dans d'autres
comme stouff karlsruhe
la glisse casse touche
ok
[Musique]
ça alors comment en pratique ça
ressemble au point dans le tournoi 4
sauf que
david sait que le roi
torride avec force
jouant de capture qui va vers l'échec
voilà
roi b6
presse que ça va faire du losc
le tour va revenir
un choix pour arrêter les plans
il ya je me brasser 7
ils vont faire un chèque il alors wade
les dispense à ses forces
et donc on parle quand ils sont bien
quatre
dans le désert de chasse et moi qu'est
ce que ça ce fut l'échec
c'est la course on tombe face à oz
option
ce ne sont pas saines
mais sega nous annonce que si ce
nom et s'appellera ou un
lance la maman fait 36.8
tu vas devoir faire trois tours d2 force
et on va faire un geste mais puisque / -
le roi fait le noir ferez le pont pour
le moins blanc il ya plus d'échecs ici
même tour d2 la finale elle perd en fait
et decroix jécistes ouf du coup thomas
leroy et ben yahia touré cheikh donc
peut-être je peux jouer jusque là
maintenant le bouclier je pars trop de
temps on va l'oublier pas faire le lemur
ah ouais tu gagnes pas
pourquoi les bars où j'aurai donc voila
voila suis imparti est jeune et on a
atteint le quart contient en plus
si vous jouez vous contredire
mais j'ai l'impression sagan ou par des
bombes à la pollution qu'on avait dit
avant moi ouais mais quatre tours et fin
septembre la mer c'est très mauvais
signe photo
ça va mais c'est d'avoir la position que
bon on a parlé
assez vraiment s'il généralement 6,47 vu
comme tout fait
mais alors tu pourras
est-ce que ça gagne entre booba ou est
ici qu arsène liban son corps qui peut
gagner juste s'est dit que c'était nul
c'est parce qu'on peut plus rien pour
les bleus ici c'est un peu une gamme
qu'est ce qu'on peut faire à part des
quatre
objets le roi donc
pas vraiment lé beau j'ai sur moi
cheikh al arkam logique
serait
pas fermé un pont si je vais à votre
porte avant et si je pouvais à bouger
pour moi
je paie c'est d'aller cacher droit
quelque part mettre ma tour aux
huitièmes
j'ai dit voilà en fait puisque les
coutures et bombay 2
parce que
j'avais le temps de faire tourner après
genou droit jetant la paix tombions
seront b deux
sur wuala
là je vois que jouer en vrai je vois pas
trop de manières d'aider shell ksh
si je me passe par là bas
là tu vas me pour montrer ainsi noir en
part par là qu'on voit toujours faire
les chèques l'on va revenir
c'est pour ça que le même profil pour
barcella la dame mais c'est un peu trop
loin parce que ça laisse le pion à 27
et si on va se cacher ici par ailleurs
la
cérémonie
cette folle envie modelo
j'ai fait ça il y avait deux là pas le
temps de faire une dame malade elle n a
jamais la perdre d'après vous faire une
station
mais ça parle non comment joue le
champion ah ouais
attendait un ok tu fait d'armes par
exemple pour prendre prise apprend à
katherine heigl
à 4 à 3 à 2
une tour ne peut plus arrêter deux pions
6 à soutenir proche de
deux pions 3 2 pour la troisième ou la
sixième avec un versement sable c'est
mieux qu'il aura donc du coup ça devrait
faire d'eux les poteaux de saut
atteindre le 40e
et donc est ce qu'un set elle est
vraiment une porte c'est de gagner ou
pas stouff à 17 selon l'ordinateur est
bon c'est tout bien oui mais juste c'est
intéressant
pour cette royaliste rod seul des quatre
sets face au tchèque il a joué
d'ailleurs c'est normal tu envoies ton
contrôler qu'une option payante peut pas
faire c'était sûr qu'il ou elle est donc
toute cette femme 624 c'était quoi la
suite alors stop pour avoir
battu faut pas mettre toi ton ordi temps
on avait un statut leur si tu veux mais
les patrons des deux tours ce qui est
là en fait tu attends dérobé 6 août
aurait chaque
impact chamakh laurent tu as m leroy en
début de finale en battant projet de
l'ain mais bon en fait et on essaie
d'aller faire moins vite ouais c'est
pourquoi tout russell pour que trois
montes écart + façade arrière
c'est ça
et si tout heureuse et je ne veux pas un
sujet pas là que je vais leur en raison
des fuites le lectorat set et là du coup
j'ai trois des sept nains
non
c'est cette seule qu'on gagne
et pourquoi donc ces sept parce que
quand tu fais le tour ces deux têtes tu
te retrouves égal pour emprise
du coup tu perds motors va devoir bouger
je crois que tu fais me tord ans et 8
ans petit
17 3 iroise et ross ouais ça avec avec
dom sur l'achat key à sémalens et si
jamais
c'est clair ils prennent tous supports
croit tout cas pas n'exagérons rien
que
sur cette cité la photo du revoir le
tour qu'alter regarde donc qu'elle soit
le roi remonte et mène pour vous varices
caché aux 8 c'est l'objectif soit le roi
des sens et du coup
il y aura ceux tel canton va se cacher
aussi vite en fait de faire d'assurer au
contraire
c est donc très dur m'a manqué
maintenant les deux la double bind mais
tu vois après tout ça en vrai je pense
que carla ni il peut la trouver il a
joué vite mais il faut tempo mais mais
mais c'est là un truc qui peut trouver
ouais mais j'ai trouvé du bonheur
là il avait il ajouté mme peau je sais
pas pourquoi il a fait
sa une sur échec même si la case et
contre
terrorisme seguin
qui n'est jamais si vite dans celui-ci
en fait on avait l'impression que la
suite de la partie gagnée pour les
blancs et ils voient un gain ils vont
d'autant food a besoin de chercher autre
chose de plus compliqué que ça ça me
semble pas si dur à avoir que ça a l'air
venu là surtout pour qu'un tel ce cas
ici qu'est ce qu'il est
cette suite a été forcé
et là il arrive en fait je vois pas du
tout des duels de tentatives
pour avoir en rouge et noir a g6 pardon
et
les blancs sont trop courts d'un temps
au fond de lui
d'ailleurs d'autres soldats on a grandi
lui ce qui n'a pas
non pas pousser son avantage contre
isbergues gourde kate n'a pas réussi à
exploiter on va passer rapidement cette
partie de milieux dernier au plus tôt
il était resté assez loin la lutte au
départ et de joie et les f4 qui donnait
un
bon avantage aux blancs alors
s'attendaient plutôt à froid vrai dire
paralyse et à pdci c'est le temps où
la course avec arme la trop belle pour
les vélos
parce que voilà lyon deux
pas du bourg de bière jargon un cavalier
sur la seconde en rouge et au cavalier
noir cavalier blanc sur la septième
essai perdu je crois parce qu'en fait le
valoir autant les bourses et hamza et
regarder les canes alliés contrôlent pas
les cases de bassoues lorenzi les gaz
c'est moins 1,2 à - the series depuis
sur son champ d'action
alors il veut revenir à environ 1,5 à
clairement ouais ce qui va réussir à
faire je pense
et c'est vrai que la position c
s'est aplatie
et vous proposer dans mon cahier
peut-être de parts et d'autres
donc les on peut tourner mais mellal
position maintenant ils ont répété ici
hockey tels à égalité d'accord
on entend des risques un petit raté une
opportunité de mettre la pression
et qu'il a bien senti stouffer la future
défaite de gates est au tout début de
stream sont et donnerait presque un
genre à dieu au nom mais en fait et en
plus c'est pas tous les jours où je joue
je joue contre mon poulain f 1 contre le
mans la fin pour le point de la route de
radars ça parce que nous rappelle le g1
pareil avec kevin et kevin a parié un
franklin cm x et aujourd'hui j'ai senti
senti les seuls que tu allais faire dans
ce sens qu'ils avaient permis faible les
magnifiques parties nostrum de droite on
va voir si on inclut et l'ajustement
immédiat war wel fuite avec cette
fameuse il est sûr de 22 des six qui est
des cinq et
le coup de grâce semble être et loire
shisi alors qu'est ce qu'il y avait
je pense à la filière quelques coups la
tour f 3 donc il veut mener c'est
peut-être
cette enquête a mené à sa perte avec les
noirs peuvent pas bouger une oreille ici
ouais donc tous rêvent cette
dame g5 donc mais à storari fans en
trois parties sur
cavaliers g4 ou g4 diane ou d'un prendre
5 le pion d'emprise comme beaucoup j'ai
fait bonne c'est que dans une position
on est bon on a une pièce d'amour des
biens beaucoup de jus pour la pièce il
la peine pièces de bois on a un fond
plus c'était mon accent avoir deux
puisqu'on adoption passé lié à sa
sélection ici kamel et bessède a déjoué
pour revenir car il est 4ème à l'est dé
6,5 c'est trop tard pour se dégager alex
qui revient mais il se fait chasser
cavale de huit
des six pour le cavalier en d5 et la
voilà c'est ma cavale et précis se prend
d'amour 8 pour
avoir du jeu mais 15
m eur ou agenda mme d'un bond à mbassa
pas l'art d'être un coût pour le coup
parce que la loi de l'adema n'arrange
rien c'est en tout cas pour le budget
donc je vais peut-être faire d'un match
5 60 euros 3 mais ici de riverains gains
cavaliers 7,7 et sauvegarde il reste 30
secondes je savais
comment il faut rester
serein
et du coup dernier baroud d'honneur en
équilibre et c'est simplement des
retards mais là il est foutu il a un
tour - options qui sont mus tre son roi
est très faible sur cases noires il doit
y avoir des termes aussi des fois on est
rentrés l'amitié mais faible
marquera le cep et puissent passer koala
sur voie f8 de peut avoir du match leur
vaut trois premiers cas déjà ce roi âge
suite
c'est quand même drôle et c'est pas cool
maintenant que j'ai regardé parce
qu'attention juste au delà c'est ce
rémois c'est ce qu'à la sofade
du siècle est-ce qu'on est cloué ne peut
pas faire dans les huit matches c'est la
déception pour les blancs
donc attention donc oui je sais parler
du pouvoir gagner
là je croyais culte du corps même temps
match 6 à 8 tours aux trois par là on
peut le faire
si
tu vois la
chaleur va le toucher 3 kg gagné six
mois aujourd'hui engine 3 et si tu vois
là j'étais moche 8 j'imagine et j'ai du
tour 3 aussi un certain abandon
faire de ganic et c'est fascinant à
celle du coup avec ce petit piège
voilà c'est plus résistants à schwyz
il va chercher bien forez peut pas
essayer de rentrer sur
sur les places alors il ya des options
sur les chèques non
sur un contre et ci
commence par 2,4
c'est bien mais gallas qui avait cet
open semaine dans la ville derrière
ça me gâche pas droit et fuite j'ai
presque dames 3 kw à part
mais où je ne veux pas besoin de fric
mais y perdraient un nom nous annonce
mais il prépare sa qu'il ferait pas sans
rappeler celle il le ferait quand même
hyper v
puisqu'ils fans du coude un peu casse
tout il n'y a en disant qu'il y avait
sept je rentre elle
peut pas sûr que je peux rentrer la
jambe de partie à toulouse où il n'y a
pas de coups
nous versons mois pour éviter le pronom
sur échec on doit pouvoir le flanc des
justement
voilà bon ok ce parlement ça devrait
aller très vite pour un vent d'euphorie
là
il ya quasiment une heure à trouver les
biens donc avec le rajout
on peut lui faire confiance c'est ce qui
fait qu'il nous reste donc cette partie
de caravanes qui devrait faire un nul à
qui devrais le perdre ou un vieux loire
singles si tu veux les anecdotes et pas
finie stouff
car voilà donc qui a été j'ai
l'impression
est très précieux toute cette séquence
de coup dur ensemble et nous sommes si
b767 siège pour ce faire une case mais
ça va pas suffire
d'un vrai mythe
turc arrivant dans le
jeu non si je vois que ça gagne pas je
n'ai pas donné ma dame en fait ça dépend
il est connu jusque là là tu vois je
soupe est un guerrier quand tu es
complètement gagnant tu vas qualité
d'assuré en public sur internet en
stream en vrai je pourrais très bien de
faire pour m'amuser parce que tout
l'après midi je me mets en partie
officielle si je suis vraiment gagnant
je vais je vais assurer si je vois que
c'est pas taire je vais le faire bien
sûr et le point mais
si par contre des faces moi j'arrivais
ça qui fait des grosses pièces comme ça
parce que je sens kral arbon etc eh ben
je veux le faire parce que ce sens que
c'est le bon coup bas mais sinon si je
le fais je sais que ça marche pas j'ai
pas de faire un pas souci des
responsables
mais en blitz je peux le faire juste
pour rigoler m'arriver parce qu'en
jouant d'un instrument n'est pas là pour
faire enfin jusqu'à moi je suis pas je
suis là pour m'amuser un peu plus
commerciaux stream est elle pour
yellowknife
bah ouais bah franchement depuis que le
stream j'ai perdu beaucoup de poids
surtout scop façon
je suis
de matech son roi dans la teinture à
prague et le tout pour le tout et mon
team gut je suis marié atif s'arrêter
roule soit envie de dire parce qu'il est
un malin avec elle cette dame et ou
parce qu'ils sont bons c'est sa
lé battait
alpha tout ça sonne bien al fath vous
comme moteur d'analysé
c'est comme fritz
est pas gentil pour fritz à
l epr efforts collectifs
[Musique]
au point de ne pas tout
- sans fidh et moi 316 moins trois sont
peut-être pas quand même n'est un bon -
239e dans la rue
tu achètes un flou après qu'ils
n'achèteraient pas le fatou ombre et
qui ne l'achèterai pas
je peux pas
manger ici je pense pas
et des réseaux n'a en fait bah ouais en
bref tout y est pour faire un gamin
menaces à un match où la demande des
pions et en même temps là c'est foutu
voir comme ça qu il reste de quoi je
veux la famille ou à rester avec lui le
temps d'attendre
la fin du zaibat
[Musique]
j'ai l'impression paris ap le bon chemin
carlo janka de victoires repas serait un
plus un don mois au positif
même si ça reste un tournoi de ce nom
pour lui au moins
moi ils arrivent à effacer s'était fait
à chaque fois par une victoire le monde
donc avec la noire c'est quand même
un signe positif pour lui
alors il doit réfléchir fait entre kg 6
et j'éprouve un quand je pense qu'il est
en train de calculer un petit peu
abbatiale pas des idées de maths parce
que
certains que la raison il tente le tout
il sait qu'il est foutu eux à son
fouquet
même canal et g600
les mac de pains tu sens qu'il ya des le
roi il est faible et en plus en fait non
seulement j'ai encore passé non
seulement j'ai tout ça mais en plus
maintenant
alors que le roi dans le
même but pour gagner et même mettre une
amende et un ca de gagner aussi oui
encore eux tu pourrais juste défendre
états d'âme en c3 mais les gars en fait
c'est qu'un jour je parle des cavaliers
en fait je vais être voué à attendre à
cause de ton disque qui a enfermé c'est
parti avec l'oph avec le fond enfin mais
depuis on reçoit beaucoup penser à
d'autres partis que j'avais travaillé
côté jaune souvent en cours
une soir domination du
du fou noir en fête
et se fout bien trop pas très content
cavalier seul par un vent nouveau
cahier c'est d'avoir tourné
forrest la panique un coup
malheureusement d'en baisser de 5 06 m
hélas quand je vais le redis je vois que
ce roi je suis costaud rage trois
ordinateurs ou fabien audard 6 à tour
validé dans cette descente sur coup
franc dès cette menace dam des huit fois
c'est vrai c'est
assez logique quand il fera froid depuis
que l'idée derrière c et c'est pourquoi
une telle manne du pouvoir dans prend
2,8 dame s'est vite qu'elle va déprendre
[Musique]
d'un médecin comme un gant
non
monsieur cavale et prend tous réfutent
on peut dire moi je tourne temps fou
j'essaie de tenir mais en fait la date
d'un
milliard confrontés
bah
oui tout simplement
ok si ouattara je trouve ça bon goût tu
vois trois c'est beau
parce que nous la scav à l'étranger 6
qui menacent même des poids du bo3
jusqu'à elle franchissait 5 et 6 3
bougez une fois que la colle pour
revivre fois que je vais rendre à
cologne avec la dame
pour moi je pensais très joli ça un joli
finish et c'est dans l'ariège john
forrest en quinze jours à mieux
esthétique qui veulent envoyer
cette idée allait passer un cap il faut
juste y penser une fois que tu poses l'a
vérifié c'est par un mot difficile
puisque la semaine du couloir et
aimerait si on essaie de pareilles dates
du courage à ses complexes
sur un coup comme touré fidji majid
liquide ou g6 jeu passion tout tout de
suite d'ailleurs mais hélas sepp blater
comme ça
merci
défense
mais bon vu que tu donnes une piaule tu
viens une fille bien quand même dans ces
cas là culte clé surtout pas maintenant
il a quand même du temps la banque du le
pen à 4 minutes
gbagbo c'est le genre h
tu vois genre en train de caler en train
de calculer tu vois tu auras je crois
mais je te pète qui va pas pouvoir voir
le pari elle est noble
on parle de quoi maintenant je prends ce
site est dangereux
non
franchement je pense que nous le prouve
donc lorsque votre boîte il va trouver
dessus des lois
manon trop mais
je vais encore une fois parce qu'on
vient d'atteindre qu'avant-hier vous
passez un moment tu as une heure pour
réfléchir tu veux trouver les liens du
sang qu'il ya un gars dont tu as besoin
qu'on tente alors je ne le voit jamais
ici c'est une chose est sûre envisage
même pas parce que je sois complexe
laffineur à la porte du le tournage 28
points
tu sens que tu as un truc sur le thème
du man du poireau je crois qu'il faut
faire et bâle s'était joué dans le gard
pour jouer sur sur khalid comme ça moi
je crois c'est la vérité
aux plus jolies mais ce qu'on peut jouer
sur avec le sacrifice sur beat mais le
tlb l'alsace en moins salut super
grouping
par le plein et tu arrive peut-être au
moment du coup de grâce à un joli coup
de grâce sylvain de vrai c'est trop
jerry ça voudrait dire que ça fait deux
années de suite qu'il est le bourreau de
gearing taux restent bas et c'est parce
qu'il avait fait dernières en retournant
à l'antenne nul mais en tout cas il y
avait battu dans les départage pour le
titre
mais les bretons restent un petit peu la
bête noire de la passion semble que il a
eu la pire score cas c'est bon projet
s'appelle
justin je serai pas vous dire au niveau
de ça mais je pense qu'il a un score
intéressant
et stouff regarde ces magnifiques en
direct à six branches toi
quelle partie du joueur des revendeurs d
un bon cru rien je veux montrer dit plus
tôt pour ceux qui étaient là avec nous
ça peut souvent mauvaises il avait
envoyé la qualité il n'y avait pas eu
peur s'est inscrite dans
jouer sur ce roi noir faible et la
broche l'état dans la colonne qui fait
la puissance 4 mais qui ne jouent pas
d'échec et est bien réel et l hyper
précis n'avait eu des bons coups
l'abandonnerai pour amener ces pièces
telles attaques
cette master class de mon voyage c'est
la parfaite et la loi gamme mazda il
sait que ça va être l'amour new
delhi qui allume basque sous le nez
l excellent site est aussi ont très bien
joué pour échanger votre quasi blanche
et sécuriser la gazelle sort pour son
cavalier
qui a forcé biri à 5 et
le matériel mais c'est s était désespéré
est vraiment un gilet vraiment y peint
les ultra ultra forts dans son style tu
vois deux
attaques comme ça et quand j'ai vu la
position en fait ça pourquoi mais j'ai
senti qu'il allait lui collait pas les
talibés et jerry sloan exactement aux
rafles s'était fait ça
difficile un gearing à mayran partie
parfaite pour pourvoir forest pas quelle
classe par classe la plus belle partie
du tournoi
intérieur de sapins de l'impression
qu'elle était propre d'une plutôt google
dans le petit jeu dans les ballades
juste magnifique cette partie est la
conclusion à la hauteur de l'ensemble de
son deuil
mais en fait moi je pense que
bon il a pris des risques avec les noirs
dit rien dans son choix d'ouverture dans
tout ça mais je pense que si vraiment tu
veux c'est de battre west faut-il voir
un truc
un truc différent ça tu vois là une
position trop compliqué trop trop
tactique quoi c'était le combat et merci
à se faire logging pour la bonne bouffe
un hardeur merci à toi à toi
je pense qu'il va prendre le temps
d'envoyer quand même guéri donc toof
oui il va y arriver il va réfléchir un
petit bois il va mais je suis pas sûr
qu'il va y avoir beaucoup de fous là je
pense qu'on aura partie restante devrait
pas trop duré et c'est pour ça qu'il ya
peut-être temps de faire potentiellement
d'autres dernière pause puisqu'il est
plus de 18h
fort de vous êtes une petite page de pub
et china bien qui fait plaisir
avant tout et d'assister à la fin de
cette même s'ils restent pas partie où
vous rappelle aussi une magnifique
victoire de marc courdes riou rizzi
aujourd'hui on 26 points avec les pièces
blanches ou encore le petit français qui
lâche ses coups et je retrouve son jeu
et c'était pas regarder la partie
vraiment un vaut le détour
voilà vous faire sauf donc on se
retrouve dans quelques minutes
[Musique]
e
oh
[Musique]
non
une obscure et 10 toof c'est parfait or
voilà
vient d'assister pendant la pause si
vous êtes encore avec nous à l'abandon
de dani gay ou sur le littoral 3 est un
petit peu bastos est un menteur tu as
fait couper les jambes
et de laisser miel
moi je vois pas qui l'a souvent
dépendantes à tout ce qui nous arrive
c'est désiste attrait que l'abandonner
les deux hommes qui disent qu est
ce qu il y avait des solutions pour
gérer par le bourg
l'impression que mon neveu est patente
injuste
brad hawpe inspire aujourd'hui
au classement général c'est quand même
les affaires de quarantaine
ça fait les affaires de kara scène on va
les voir ce qu'un sauvegarde est nul il
est pas qui de toute façon un changement